beziehungsweise spitzenkandidaten der
zukünftig im deutschen bundestag
vertretenen parteien
wir melden uns hier live aus dem alten
telegrafenamt aus der mitte der
hauptstadt
deutschland hat gewählt und es gibt auf
jeden fall einen neuen kanzler nach 16
jahren angela merkel wer regiert mit wem
und wer sitzt künftig auf den
oppositionsbänken zwei anmerkungen noch
alle anwesenden hier sind frisch und
negativ getestet und wir diskutieren
hier auf dem stand der hochrechnungen
kurz nach 20 uhr
wohin geht deutschland und mit welcher
regierungskonstellation
darüber wollen rainald becker und ich
diskutieren mit dem
spd-kanzlerkandidaten olaf scholz dem
gemeinsamen kanzler kandidaten von
cdu/csu armin laschet mit der
kanzlerkandidatin der grünen annalena
baerbock dem fdp-parteivorsitzenden
christian lindner mit der
spitzenkandidatin der afg alice weidl
der linken chefin susanne hennig welt so
und den csu parteivorsitzenden markus
söder allen hier an der runde der
momentan ganz herzlich willkommen und
natürlich innen auch liebe zuschauer und
herzlich willkommen auch von mir herr
scholz sie sind ich sag mal vielleicht
der sieger des abends es wird ja immer
noch gezielt genau wissen wir das noch
nicht aber unabhängig davon aus dem
ergebnis was bisher bekannt ist leiten
sie daraus den anspruch für eine
regierungsbildung ab und werfen sie
zuerst an wen bieten sie
sondierungsgespräche
zunächst mal ist das votum der bürger
und bürger sehr eindeutig die balken bei
der spd sind nach oben gegangen und nach
den gegenwärtigen umfragen sind die spd
ergebnisse auch so dass wir in allen
umfragen vorne liegen das ist eine
ermutigende botschaft und wie ich finde
auch ein sehr klarer auftrag jetzt dafür
zu sorgen dass wir eine gute
pragmatische regierung für deutschland
zustande kriegen die sich mit den
wichtigsten zukunftsaufgaben beschäftigt
die wirtschaft mehr respekt in unserer
gesellschaft zu organisieren
wie wir das hinbekommen dass wir die
industrielle modernisierung in
deutschland auf den weg bringen und dass
wir den menschen gemacht klimawandel
aufhalten und das wird in den nächsten
tagen und wochen zu klären sein
möglichst schnell übrigens aus meiner
sicht aber wen sie zuerst anrufen wollen
sie nicht verraten ja ich habe ja schon
immer gesagt dass ich finde dass das
große schnittmengen gibt hier zum
beispiel aber es wird ja nicht alleine
reichen deshalb wird es zu dritt sein
müssen und das glaube ich wird sich in
kurzer zeit klären ich jedenfalls glaube
dass es der respekt vor den bürgern und
bürgern gebietet dass wir auch die
endgültige auszählung aller ergebnisse
abwarten und dann wird man klar sehen
aber mein wunsch ist konstruktiv mit
beachtung all der ansatzpunkte die von
unterschiedlichen parteien eingebracht
werden so dass sich jeder und auch das
ganze land in einer regierung
wiederfinden herr laschet mit einem
verlust zur vergangenen bundestagswahl
von etwa 8 punkten verzeichnet die union
die höchsten verluste des abends das
stimmt es ist auch das schwächste
ergebnis dass cdu und csu bei der
bundestagswahl erzielt haben sie haben
wir da haben schon gesagt sie wollen
trotzdem kanzler werden aber ist das
nicht der situation ein resultat bei dem
ein parteivorsitzender auch an
persönliche konsequenzen denken muss
also erst mal ist das natürlich ein
verlust an stimmen der nicht schön ist
wir haben eine situation erlebt dass zum
ersten mal nach 16 jahren angela merkel
die bundeskanzlerin nicht mehr
angetreten ist also insofern hat niemand
einen amtsbonus bei dieser wahl und das
wahlergebnis ist jetzt so dass sich aus
der mitte des deutschen bundestages eine
neue regierung ergeben muss das hat uns
der wähler aufgetragen es ist keine
partei so stark dass sie es alleine kann
und deshalb für das jetzt darauf
ankommen aus der mitte des bundestages
so viele gemeinsamkeiten wie möglich zu
finden zwischen einem wahrscheinlich
erstmals dreierbündnis aus drei
politischen partei familien im moment
lägen sie auf nummer zwei in den beiden
umfragen von ard und zdf das kann sich
noch ändern aber wenn sie wirklich auf
zwei landen halten sie dann am anspruch
fest ins kanzleramt einzuziehen und
gleiche frage wie bei olaf scholz in
welcher konstellation hätte erwerben sie
heute abend habe er gerade beschrieben
wer bundeskanzler in deutschland wird
muss es schaffen
unterschiedliche fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages zusammen zu
bringen
und dann am ende eine mehrheit zu haben
das war in allen 70 jahren der
bundesrepublik so nicht immer weil die
partei die auf 1 war auch die den
kanzler stellt und deshalb ist das jetzt
die große aufgabe der demokratischen
parteien zu sehen wo gibt es die größten
gemeinsamkeiten
ich glaube die zeit die vor uns liegt
braucht als erstes wirtschaftliche
stärke und stabilität
marktwirtschaftliche lösungen sie
braucht einen großen schub in der
verwaltung des landes bei der
digitalisierung und das thema
klimaschutz hat gerade in diesem
jahrzehnt die aufgabe eine ganze
industrie gesellschaft frage herr
laschet die csu hat es ja anders gesehen
sie hat gesagt aus der position zwei
kann man das kanzleramt nicht
beanspruchen ich habe gerade die
verfassungslage geschildert und markus
söder hat heute auch die position der
csu erläutert
insofern ist es doch jetzt eindeutig es
geht ja nicht darum dass man
arithmetisch irgendwie eine mehrheit
zusammen kriegt sagt ich wünsche mir
eine regierung wo auch jeder partner
vorkommt wo auch jeder sichtbar ist
keine regierung allein der kanzler mit
seinen punkten glänzen kann sondern wo
unterschiedliche politische positionen
so zusammengeführt werden dass das auch
eine koalition ist die man gerne macht
das war in der großen koalition am ende
nicht mehr so der fall also das kann ein
bündnis werden was wirklich deutschland
voran bringt unterschiedliche richtungen
versöhnt und dazu stehe ich bereit also
darum das nochmal klasse mal sie sitzen
ja mit herrn laschet und dem unions
ergebnis sozusagen in einem boot wenn
sich der zweite platz der es im moment
ist verstetigt und bestätigt leiten sie
daraus einen regierungsanspruch ab also
zum ersten mal ist noch nicht ganz klar
wie das ergebnis wirklich ausgeht sie
haben es vorhin schon angesprochen es
schwankt auch zwischen prozenten und
dann den sitzenden deutschen bundestag
in einigen umfragen bei der ard liegt
die union sogar bei der fraktions zahl
von abgeordneten vorne was auch einen
eigenen führungsanspruch noch einmal
zusätzlich wäre aber am ende kommt es
tatsächlich ab wenn die deutschen am
ende dieses regierungs und anvertrauen
schauen sie es gab ja lange dieses
modell rot rot grün das hat heute schon
eine klatsche bekommen die deutschen
möchten nicht rotor können und dieses
misstrauen gegen rotor königs indirekt
auch ein misstrauen gegen olaf scholz
denn er hat diese idee favorisiert das
sind glaube ich kein bündnis des gestern
oder rückwärts gewandt sondern eine idee
wirklich wie deutschland stabil bleibt
und wie wir erneuern können und ich
glaube dass wir diesen anspruch gut mit
armin laschet dokumentieren können
vielleicht mit der fdp und mit den
grünen zusammen weil ich glaube da ist
der größte wunsch nach veränderung da
nach reform und erneuerung und wir
bieten dann an der richtige partner
dafür zu sein trotzdem die nachfrage
muss heute abend glaube ich auch
gestellt werden bei dem verlust den cdu
und csu eingefahren haben wäre das
ergebnis mit ihnen besser gewesen für
ihre partei waren sie ja der kandidat
der herzen
das ist wirklich schnee von gestern und
bringt uns ja auch in dieser schwierigen
situation die welt hätten gar nichts wir
haben die letzten zwei wochen noch mal
wirklich an tollen schlussspurt
hingelegt und ich muss es auch mal ganz
menschlich persönlich sagen ich habe
großen respekt vor armin laschet denn in
diesem wahlkampf ist immer so viel
unernst haft ausgesprochen worden also
auch über lebensläufe über über lacher
über all diese dinge anstatt sich über
die ernsten fragen zu beschäftigen und
nämlich viel wie ich finde unrecht getan
worden und deswegen hat er meinen
respekt und meine unterstützung auch für
diese auseinandersetzung frau werburg
gemessen am ausgangspunkt im april/mai
zählen sie heute abend auch zu den
verlierern mit einem wahrscheinlich doch
auch für sie enttäuschenden
stimmenzuwachses gibt den zuwachs aber
sie wollten ja sehr viel mehr war der
anspruch doch zu groß die erste grüne
kanzlerin zu werden und warum hat es
nicht geklappt trotz der flutkatastrophe
trotz des klimawandels das sind doch
eigentlich alles themen die für sie auf
sie heraus liefen ja offensichtlich
haben wir unser grünes wahlziel was wir
ausgegeben hatten eine führende kraft in
diesem land zu sein nicht erreicht
sondern sind weit darunter geblieben wie
enttäuscht sind sie heute abend dass das
nicht nur grund zur freude ist das ist
ziemlich klar aber es war absolut
richtig die union herauszufordern
deutlich zu machen wir brauchen in
deutschland eine erneuerung und unserem
land demokratie lebt von alternativen
und das hat für den wahlkampf auch eine
ganz andere dynamik gegeben die nächste
bundesregierung die muss eine klima
regierung sein das ist der klare auftrag
nach dieser wahl wir haben unsere
stimmen deutlich deutlich verbessert und
das ist auch der klare auftrag für uns
grüne dass das jetzt in der nächsten
bundesregierung umgesetzt wird und dafür
tragen sie auch die verantwortung dass
jetzt zu tun weil die herausforderung
gehen jetzt ja nicht weg bloß weil das
wahlergebnis vorliegt sondern eine
erneuerung dieses landes ist jetzt das
oberste gebot für die nächste deutsche
bundesregierung darüber sprechen wir
gleich noch mal aber ich will sie auch
noch mal fragen zehn prozentpunkte mehr
als auf dem höchststand der umfragen im
april was heißt das jetzt auch für die
machtarithmetik bei den grünen in ihrer
partei ist so bitter das für sie
vielleicht ist ab heute abend robert
habeck die nummer eins mit den grünen ja
wir haben bereits im frühjahr deutlich
gemacht dass wir in die sondierung als
team gehen wir haben eine
kanzlerkandidatin für diesen im
wahlkampf aufgestellt weil wir führende
kraft in diesem land werden wollten
dieses land anführen wollten dass es
nicht gelungen offensichtlich aber wir
haben den klaren wählerinnen und wähler
auftrag für eine neuerung in diesem land
zu sorgen dass werden robert habeck und
ich gemeinsam in diesen sondierung
genauso machen und sie hatten gefragt
was passiert mit blick auch auf den
sommer wir hatten das duell in den
ersten monaten mit der union und die
entscheidende frage war wer wird der
nächste bundesregierung gibt es eine
echte erneuerung und in dem moment wo
die spd uns überholt hat es ist ein
wettstreit zwischen den beiden parteien
geworden so bitter für uns das jetzt ist
aber wie gesagt das was jetzt gemacht
werden muss das hat sich dadurch nicht
verändert und das bedeutet deutschland
klimaneutral zu gestalten berliner ein
bisschen dazu gewonnen und sie gelten
als königsmacher aber allein mit der
union werden dass gerade schon wird's ja
nicht reichen sie müssen sich also mit
den grünen mit frau berg irgendwie
arrangieren heißt es diesmal bei der fdp
lieber mit einem ungeliebten partner
regieren als gar nicht regieren
die fdp war und ist bereit verantwortung
zu übernehmen wir regieren auch in ganz
unterschiedlichen formaten in
deutschland beispielsweise in nordrhein
westfalen mit armin laschet in einer
schwarz gelben koalition
es gibt in schleswig-holstein jamaika es
gibt eine ampelkoalition in
rheinland-pfalz und in sachsen anhalt
eine sogenannte deutschland koalition
wir sind auch sehr eigenständig in
diesem wahlkampf gegangen es gab ja
sogar bisweilen kampagnen der union
gegen die fdp wir sind eigenständig in
diesen wahlkampf gegangen und wir gehen
jetzt auch eigenständig aus dieser wahl
heraus wir haben für unsere inhalte
geworben für eine politik der mitte für
den wert der freiheit den gedanken dass
der wohlstand erst erwirtschaftet werden
muss bevor verteilt werden kann wir
wenden uns gegen verbote und für eine
offenheit für technologie und mit dieser
eigenständigen inhaltlichen positionen
gehen wir in gesprächen das heißt aber
sie reden auch mit olaf scholz und
seiner spd denn die ampel könnte ja die
denkbar stärkste option sein nun ja das
wahlergebnis ist nicht ganz einfach zu
lesen zunächst sehen wir dass die
politischen ränder geschwächt sind und
die politische mitte gestärkt ist wir
sehen dann dass keine der früheren
volksparteien mehr als 75 oder mehr als
25 26 prozent erzielt hat also etwa 75
prozent der deutschen haben die partei
eines nächsten kanzlers nicht gewählt
und deshalb herr becker könnte es ratsam
sein dass die parteien die gegen den
status quo der großen koalition
wahlkampf gemacht haben die aus einer
unterschiedlichen perspektive heraus
diesen status quo überwinden wollten das
also grüne und fdp zuerst miteinander
sprechen um dann all das was danach
kommt zu strukturieren kurze nachfrage
formel wird wenn sie dazu bereit
sozusagen zuerst mit der nicht zu
sprechen bevor die großen die wahlsieger
12 daran sind wir bereits in den letzten
tagen ja auch deutlich gemacht robert
habeck und ich dass diese logik da ist
einer der alle anderen anruft dass diese
logik dem aufbruch den wir in unserem
land brauchen nicht gut tut und deswegen
ist es mehr als sinnvoll dass
unterschiedliche parteien jetzt seinen
unterschiedlichen kombinationen
miteinander sprechen gespräch findet ja
jetzt auch schon hier in dieser runde
statt freundlich werde so überraschender
weise vertreten sie nun statt ihrer
spitzenkandidatin janine wissler die
linke die partei die linke in dieser
runde sie kämpfen aktuell noch um den
einzug in den bundestag das kann noch
schief gehen um diese zeit hatten sie
die falsche spitzenkandidatin war sie
einfach zu links zu abgehoben von
händlern nein auf keinen fall janine
wissen dietmar bartsch am einen
hervorragenden wahlkampf geführt dass
wir in den vergangenen jahren viele
fehler gemacht haben das zeigt auch
dieses ergebnis dass es mit sicherheit
nicht in den letzten wochen entstanden
sondern es ist ein zeitraum in dem wir
uns in bestimmten themen nicht
entschieden haben wo wir keine klarheit
gezeigt haben und es ist natürlich auch
so dass wir nach 30 jahren opposition im
bundestag sehr schwer darstellen können
dass auch wir bereit sind verantwortung
zu tragen wir tun das in den einzelnen
bundesländern und können das auch bodo
ramelow zeigt insofern ja sie haben
recht für uns ist das kein schöner abend
und es wird ein sehr langer arm werden
ich gehe davon aus dass wir tatsächlich
im deutschen bundestag verbleiben werden
und wir werden die vier jahren natürlich
nutzen um uns weiter zu entwickeln und
die stärker wiederzukommen frau weiter
bei ihnen ist es eigentlich relativ
einfach keiner will mit ihnen sie haben
stimmen verloren woran liegt das am
internen streit an der schlechten
oppositionsarbeit
wo sehen sie die ursachen
wir sind sehr zufrieden mit dem ergebnis
wir sind zweistellig geblieben
man hat uns ja prognostiziert dass die
afg eine eintagsfliege im bundestag ist
dass man uns nach der ersten legislatur
auch wieder aus dem bundestag hinaus
wirft das haben wir wieder legt wir
können auf eine sehr solide
stammwählerschaft zählen und wir haben
natürlich
also jetzt gleich den vergleich gezogen
haben zu den wahlen 2017 haben wir
natürlich hier ein sondereffekt den
antritt im bundesweiten der freien
wähler die natürlich ganz klar in
unserem fahrwasser gesegelt sind als
auch eine sehr corona kritische partei
die basis und wenn man diese
sondereffekte
bereinigt dann
liegen wir sogar über dem ergebnis von
2017 also wir konnten uns deutlich
verbessern und das zeug natürlich auch
von unserer sehr guten oppositionsarbeit
und der abend ist ja noch lang wir
schauen was die prognosen noch bringen
werden morgen haben wir dann die
ergebnisse vielleicht auch spät heute
abend und dementsprechend sehen weder
sehr sehr gelassen und auch gut gelaunt
in die nächste legislatur herr scholz
sie streben an die nachfolge von angela
merkel zu übernehmen mit einem so
schwachen wahlergebnis wie noch nie
zuvor ein kanzler in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik erzielt hat ich will das
aufgreifen was herr lindner gesagt hat
man könnte auch sagen mehr als 70
prozent der wählerinnen und wähler haben
sich eben nicht für sie entschieden und
zum ersten mal wird ein kanzler seine
macht mit zwei parteien teilen müssen
wenn es zu dem von ihnen favorisierten
ampel modell kommt grünen und fdp und es
könnte sein dass die beiden kleinen
zusammen genauso groß sind wie sie sind
sie jetzt sozusagen ein während sie dann
ein schwacher koch mit zwei staaten
kellnern und mal gerhard schröder zu
aufzugreifen
mit diesem koch und kellner vergleichen
habe ich es noch nie so richtig gehabt
das finde ich falsch ich glaube es geht
immer darum dass man auf augenhöhe
miteinander zusammen arbeitet und dazu
gehört auch dass man
versucht dinge so zusammen zu binden
dass es im ergebnis dazu führt dass
unser land ein fortschritt macht also es
geht nicht nur um geschäftsführer
logischen von parteien sondern dass alle
sich auch in deutschland das ist eine
andere machtarithmetik als zum beispiel
bei rot grün so die erst mit der sehr
viel größer war als deko das ist anders
klar wobei ich gerne mit dem bemerken
glauben darf manchmal wirkte die
aktuelle koalition auch wie eine drei
parteien koalition das kann ich nicht
verleugnen ist sie auch sagt herr söder
also stelle ich auch und insofern habe
ich schon ein bisschen übung aber
unabhängig von dieser frage wenn wir uns
umschauen in unseren nachbarländern
finden wie viele länder in denen das
längst und zwar sehr lange realität ist
insofern finde ich wird es schon gehen
es geht um eine regierung die
vernünftige zielsetzung hat und sich
auch miteinander vornimmt gut zu
regieren durchaus mit einer perspektive
dass man sagt wenn wir dann antreten
zusammen wollen wir auch gemeinsam
wieder gewählt werden das kann nicht so
sein wie ich das wahrgenommen hat mit
der schwarz-gelben koalition die mal
kurz
regiert hatte mache mir noch ein
bisschen analyse sozusagen des
wahlergebnisses herr scholz rot grün rot
ist stand jetzt keine option mehr sie
haben immer daran festgehalten dass es
auch eine variante für die spd sein
könnte war das ein fehler eine solche
koalition sich offen zu halten haben sie
damit nicht am ende den wahlkampf der
union angefeuert ich glaube ich nicht
wir haben ja auch im übrigen nicht das
getan sollen wir haben gesagt wir wollen
dass die bürgerinnen bürger entscheiden
wie die parteien und mit welcher stärke
sehen den deutschen bundestag gehen und
haben all diese versuchungen den nicht
nachgegangen monate vor der wahl schon
die regierung zu bilden und das ist ja
eigentlich kein großer respekt vor den
wählern und wähler wenn man so vorgeht
es muss schon so sein das wir sehen wie
wollen die das haben und die haben ja
viel geändert die spd ist stärker
geworden als bei den letzten wahlen sie
ist aber auch noch viel stärker geworden
als in den umfragen vor einigen wochen
und monaten und insofern glaube ich ist
hier schon ein sehr sehr eindeutiges
votum will das mal so sagen es gibt ein
paar parteien die hier am tisch sitzen
die haben zuwächse erzielt die spd einen
sehr großen die grünen die fdp und
andere haben keine zuwächse erzielt auch
das ist eine botschaft
verlassen
olaf scholz will kanzler werden sie
wollen es auch jetzt reden wir mal
darüber wenn sie es nicht werden und sie
nummer zwei sind was was bleibt dann was
raten sie ihrer partei erneuerung in der
opposition
juniorpartner der spd und dann die frage
muss auch heute abend glaube ich mal
gestellt werden könnten sie dann
parteivorsitzender bleiben
wir haben noch nicht mal alle ergebnisse
wir warten noch darauf wir haben heute
doch erkannt kanzler wird nur jemand der
eine mehrheit im deutschen bundestag hat
und deshalb würde ich doch und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch die erwartung der
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer erst jetzt
mal sehen welche richtung soll das land
nehme nur welche themen reden wäre das
ist doch jetzt die kernfrage und nicht
die selbstbeschäftigung was wird aus wem
wenn dieses oder jenes eintritt wir
werden das dann in der union besprechen
wenn der zeitpunkt da ist jetzt ist der
zeitpunkt da zu sehen wie kriegen wir
für dieses land eine regierung in dieser
lage in der wir stehen mitten in europa
wir haben ja viel zu wenig wie ich finde
auch in den tri allen hier haben wir die
am letzten donnerstag mal gesprochen
über europa und internationale politik
ganz europa schaut im moment was wird
aus deutschland und eine lage das am
wahlabend nicht klar war wer wird
kanzler hat deutschland in der form auch
ganz selten nur gehabt aber gerade
deshalb stellt sich ja die frage es gab
schon mal die situation da ging dann nur
noch eine option die option wäre
rechnerisch auch möglich kann die cdu
nummer zwei
jetzt haben wir nach meiner einschätzung
ist jeder der meinung dass diese große
koalition auch der arbeitsstil dieser
großen koalition nicht zukunftsträchtig
ist egal wer nun 1 oder 2 wir brauchen
hier einen echten neuanfang der auch
nicht so erzwungen wird die große
koalition war ja auch bei der spd muss
man ja an erkennen nicht dass wunsch
konzept 2018 wir haben ja jamaika
versucht es hat dann aus vielen gründen
nicht funktioniert und dann hat man
irgendwie nur einmal große koalition
gemacht und das was jetzt beginnt
muss auch den reiz haben dass man sagt
ja da kommen unterschiedliche
gesellschaftliche strömungen zusammen da
entsteht was das vielleicht wirklich
diesem land einen neuen schub geben kann
auch mit den dingen die man lösen
wirtschaft und ökologie noch stärker
versöhnen als bisher wenn das alles
nicht geleert wir sind für die
opposition nicht aus dass wir damals
gelingen denken herr becker und nicht
als nicht belegen ich bin immer ein
mensch der uns gelingen denkt und der
will dass jetzt etwas gutes für
deutschland entsteht sind mir ans
gelingen denken sie sich ja auch gerne
zünglein an der waage ist die liberale
traumrolle heute abend gibt es aber
vielleicht zwei zünglein sie haben ja
bisher eher auf ein bündnis mit der
union gesetzt und den grünen was muss
olaf scholz ihn bieten damit ist auch
eine ampelkoalition werden kann und muss
vielleicht ein bisschen konkreter zu
machen frau baerbock sagte eben es muss
eine klima koalition werden ist das ein
stichwort mit dem sie leben könnten oder
fängt hier der zwist schon an wer jetzt
haben sie einerseits nach den scholz
gefragt und andererseits wer wodka so
frau berbalk zitiert
ich habe die parteiprogramme alle
gelesen und wenn man das tut stellt man
fest dass die größten inhaltlichen
übereinstimmungen zwischen den
unionsparteien und der fdp sind das habe
ich vor der wahl gesagt und das will ich
nach der wahl auch ausdrücklich
wiederholen für uns sind die ideen von
steuer erhöhe oder aufweichen der
schuldenbremse auch nach der wahl noch
keine akzeptablen ideen ich glaube alle
nächste regierung wird
sehr viel ökologischer sein man muss ja
das ergebnis der grünen zur kenntnis
nehmen sehr viele menschen in unserem
land die sie eine höhere ökologische
sensibilität der politik wünschen das
wird in einer nächsten regierung
notwendig seien auch umzusetzen und zum
anderen wenn ich sehe welche gutes
ergebnis die fdp erzielt hat mit unserem
einsatz für technologieoffenheit für die
bürgerlichen freiheitsrechte für eine
stärkung unseres wirtschaftlichen
aufschwungs so ist meine erwartung dass
sich auch dieser gedanke in einer
nächsten koalition wieder findet aber
eins er frei wenn sie den gedanken noch
kurz gestatten 1 ist an diesem abend
doch glaube ich eine gute nachricht die
uns verbindet anders als in anderen
europäischen
demokratien wird in deutschland einer
regierungsbildung eine koalitionsbildung
aus dem demokratischen zentrum der
politik möglich sein ränder werden dafür
nicht benötigt es eine gute nachricht
weil all diejenigen in europa und
darüber hinaus die sorgen hatten um die
stabilität deutschlands können jetzt
erkennen deutschland wird in jedem fall
stabil bleiben über sätze gesagt handelt
man sie sagen im prinzip bin ich auch
mit spd und grünen koalitionsfähig wir
regieren in rheinland-pfalz aber
trotzdem wäre ihre schlussfolgerung
falsch wenn sie daraus schließen würden
dass das eine präferierte option ist uns
geht es um inhalte es war die frage eben
von herrn becker auch vor vier jahren
hätten wir ja ein jamaika-bündnis machen
können war damals war die idee von union
und grünen dass die fdp nur einen
schwarz grünen koalitionsvertrag
unterschreiben sollten unsere inhalt
haben keine rolle gespielt und das muss
und wird sich jetzt ändern
und ich kann nur sagen ich würde mich
wenn es zu jamaika gesprächen kommt ich
würde mich immer dafür einsetzen dass
union und fdp mit den grünen fairer
umgehen als union und grünen das 2017
mit der fdp gab sich länder dann fragen
wir doch die grünen frau burke sie haben
wie die fdp im grunde zwei möglichkeiten
mitzuregieren wäre denn ein bündnis mit
cdu und fdp ihrer basis überhaupt
vermittelbar gibt es dafür eine mehrheit
in ihrer partei bei uns gibt es eine
deutliche mehrheit und das ist unser
auftrag und das ist auch der auftrag
dieses wahlabends dass die nächste
bundesregierung die weichen dafür
stellen muss dass dieses land in den
nächsten zwei jahrzehnten klimaneutral
wird und das ist dann nicht nur ein
ressort was dafür verantwortlich ist
sondern das bedeutet mit blick auf die
industrie an die diesen falschen
eingeschlagen hat jetzt alle leitplanken
so zu setzen damit deutschland diesen
vater klimaneutralität nicht nur geht
sondern dafür sorgt die in den letzten
jahrhundert dass der wohlstand dieses
landes dadurch gesichert wird das zieht
sich durch durch das verkehrsministerium
durch das landwirtschaftsministerium und
das ist die große aufgabe der nächsten
bundesregierung und deswegen ist mein
auftrag meine verantwortung als nur eine
parteivorsitzende gemeinsam mit robert
habeck das zu erörtern wo können wir
dieser großen verantwortung die wir
nicht nur als partei sondern als land in
der welt haben gerecht werden und da
muss man mit allen akteuren dann
gemeinsam das
macht es ja keinen sinn zu sagen wir
machen neuen koalitionsvertrag es geht
nicht um den kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenner sondern es geht jetzt wirklich in
diesem historischen moment die weichen
für die zukunft zu stellen und uns haben
sehr sehr viele junge menschen im land
gewählt und da sind wir ganz vorne
führende kraft gewesen und das ist nicht
nur eine frage von klimaschutz die frage
ist eine generationsgerechtigkeit frage
und der muss man verantwortungsvoll
gerecht werden kassel wir reden gleich
nochmal über inhalte auch an sie will
ich die frage stellen was eigentlich so
das hauptthema dieser koalition sein
könnte die sie formen wollen aber
nochmal zur analyse die csu hat unter
ihrer führung bei den landtagswahlen
schlecht abgeschnitten sie rutscht auch
heute abend noch einmal tiefer höher als
der bundesdurchschnitt der union aber
doch ein ergebnis mit dem sie sicher
nicht zufrieden sind tragen sie dafür
auch persönlich verantwortung haben sie
zu lange gegen armin laschet gekämpft
stadt für ihn
wir haben bei der letzten europawahl das
beste geben es aller parteien ansieht in
deutschland mit 40 prozent werden bei
der kommunalwahl in bayern große erfolge
ziel indem wir städte wie nürnberg und
augsburg geholt haben aber ja sagen
beruf stärker absturz habe was sie sagen
immer man muss sie die ergebnisse immer
im kontext sehen ja wir haben unser
ergebnis ist nicht ausreichend das ist
absolut so das hängt unter anderem auch
ein bisschen es wurden sogar
freigesprochen den freien wählern die in
stärkeren punkte gemacht haben was ich
sehr bedauere übrigens weil diese
vielleicht zwei drei prozent der freien
wähler könnten dann möglicherweise ein
echtes bürgerliches bündnis gefährden
deswegen war das ein schwerer fehler der
freien wähler dies zu tun aber zurück
haben uns gefällt das ergebnis nicht wir
haben aber glaube ich kann man sagen
haben in den letzten wochen noch mal
deutlich tempo gemacht gemeinsam und ich
glaube der parteitag der csu auch die
abschlussveranstaltung das war echter
rückenwind an das kann ich sagen wir
tragen immer alle gemeinsam die
verantwortung dass es bei solchen
wahlergebnis nur relativ schnell zu
gewesen wir tragen immer alle gemeinsam
die verantwortung und ich glaube dass
mit unserem schlussspurt wir noch vieles
nach vorne gebracht haben und jetzt muss
man halt 1 1 aus diesem ergebnis auch
eine regierung bilden ich meine ich
finde schon dass das nach diesen 16
jahren ist schon ein bedürfnis gibt
viele menschen nach veränderung
herausforderungen die da sind und die
müssen wir angehen und ich muss mal
kraftvoll angenehmes mitführung angehen
die kann man nicht nur so verwalten
jetzt ein bisschen wie urlaub schulzes
quasi mit einer hochwertigen notariellen
funktion versehen dann muss auch ein
bisschen kraft trainer sein da muss
ideen da muss auch zukunftsvisionen
dahinter sein und ich glaube die
substanz ist bei uns mit abstand am
stärksten und jetzt wird klar jetzt ein
bisschen taktiert jeder sagt verweist
man auf seinem programm aber alle werden
aus der komfortzone gehen müssen alle
müssen mal aus diesen aus diesen
parteien nischen raus und dann auf den
tisch legen was ist möglich was ist
eigentlich halb so lang persönlich um
diese kraft auf die schiene zu bringen
auch nach berlin wechseln so
ungewöhnlich das wäre für den
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten und ich
bin hier da und wieder auch gern in der
runde hier und freue mich wenn sie auch
öfters ist ich glaube dass wir wenn es
diese konstellation in hier so sehen
wird ja zunächst mal gerade am anfang
eine große verantwortung auf den
koalitionsausschuss kommen also nach
meiner erfahrung der letzten jahre war
das auch so dass der koalitionsausschuss
eine zentrale bedeutung hat und da bin
ich als parteivorsitzender dann glaube
ich da und denke mal so dass wir
zusammen die beiden parteivorsitzenden
da eine große rolle spielen ich glaube
sogar historisch gesehen bin ich eine
der freundlicheren
csu-vorsitzenden zumindest was unsere
gemeinsame ist verhältnis mit der cdu
betrifft so jetzt freihändigen also
heute abend sie müssen nicht taktieren
bei ihnen geht es eigentlich um die
existenz in den letzten wahlergebnissen
auch heute abend sind sie dauerhaft
hinter auch in ihren hochburgen im osten
dauerhaft hinter der afd was machen sie
falsch warum laufen die wähler davon und
setzen sie möglicherweise auf die falt
auf die falschen themen die sahra
wagenknecht ihnen ja vorgeworfen hat
also zunächst natürlich
das was wir verloren haben dass wir mal
am heutigen abend nicht gut machen und
hoffen natürlich dass wir im deutschen
bundestag bleiben diejenigen die
tatsächlich verlieren sind ja diejenigen
die die sogenannte mitte koalition die
jetzt hier schon von verschiedenen
seiten geschmiedet wird eben vergisst
und das sind die millionen menschen die
in diesem land nach 16 jahren unions
regierung tatsächlich gar nicht genug
geld haben um leben zu können die ent
bürger engten wohnverhältnissen leben
die sich keinen urlaub leisten können
die 40 prozent und mehr ihres einkommens
für die miete zahlen es sind die
rentnerinnen und rentner die auf eine
rentenerhöhung angewiesen sind es sind
diejenigen die einen höheren mindestlohn
brauchen um überhaupt ein einkommen zu
haben dann was armut fest ist und all
das versteht diese mitte nicht alte ihr
problem das aber auch mit meinen
eindruck heute an schulden aber das sind
ja dann nicht die die sie wählen weil
sonst würden sie nicht um die fünf
prozent hürde kämpfen na ja ich würde
sagen es gibt einen deutlichen
widerspruch in dem das wir aus meiner
sicht durchaus die richtige frage nicht
die soziale frage in diesem land stellen
weil sie erheblich stellt auch was den
sozialen zusammenhang unsere
gesellschaft angeht und dem widerspruch
dass uns menschen nicht vertrauen dass
tatsächlich durchsetzen können da haben
sie recht ich habe ja auch zu beginn
gesagt dass wir in der vergangenheit
auch fehler gemacht haben dass werden
uns anschauen aber in einem bin ich mir
sicher dass bei der nächsten regierung
nicht darum geht dass armin laschet spaß
beim regierung hat zu sagen es geht
darum auch diejenigen in den blick zu
nehmen die tatsächlich in arm und in
diesem land nehmen und das sind
millionen und nicht nur wenige bevor sie
haben für ihn behauptet sie seien
glücklich an diesem abend und mit diesem
wahlergebnis dabei ist ihre partei mehr
denn je zerrissen zwischen völkischer
radikalopposition und einem flügel der
mitregieren will nach ihrer niederlage
heute abend das ist es ist eine
niederlage
es gibt keine option mitzuregieren und
sie haben stimmen verloren müssen sie
sich dann nicht langsam mal entscheiden
zwischen erneuten und ein höcker
nein die unterscheidung muss man nicht
treffen und ich möchte das auch
zurückweisen was hier gerade gesagt
haben völkisch national das gibt es bei
uns nicht und das weiss ich ganz weit
von mir
dass ich viel interessanter finde auch
während des wahlkampfes sind auch heute
abend das beispielsweise die grünen die
hier eine klima regierung anstreben
hierzu der mitte zu der politischen
mitte in deutschland stilisiert wird
also wenn wir jetzt mittlerweile schon
so weit die grünen als koalitionspartner
überhaupt an zu denken
dann kann ich einfach nur sagen gute
nacht industriestandort bundesrepublik
deutschland also ich denke mal in vier
jahren wenn wir uns hier wieder sehen
werden die verhältnisse ganz ganz anders
liegen
bis heute abend haben sie alle hier am
tisch als wahlkämpfer ihre inhaltlichen
positionen vorgetragen jetzt müssen aus
versprechungen kompromisse werden
deshalb fragen wir jetzt wo sind sie
bereit abstriche zu machen um
koalitionen bilden zu können damit das
ganze nicht wieder so ein quälender
prozess wird wie
2017 beginnen wollen wir mit den
parteien auf die es jetzt ankommt herr
lindner es geht jetzt um gemeinsamkeiten
mit den grünen haben sie schon mal
angedeutet gleich ob in einer ampel oder
in einer jamaika-koalition sie werden
gebraucht um diese regierung zu bilden
was tut ihnen denn mehr weh die
solardach pflicht oder der verzicht auf
steuersenkung der das bedeuten könnte
oder lässt sich aktive klimapolitik am
ende doch mit entlastung für den
steuerzahler kombinieren
herr frei also ich fühle mich
überfordert jetzt koalitionsgespräche in
einer fernseh live sendung an zu streng
aber die leute und das ist ja so als in
welche richtung sie sich bewegen ja wohl
nicht nur das amtliche endergebnis haben
aber ich will ihnen gern vorschlag
machen wir haben ja vor der wahl bereits
ins gespräch gebracht ein super
abschreibungs programm wo private anlage
investitionen die dem klimaschutz und
der digitalisierung dienen schnell
steuerlich wirksam würden das hätte
einen doppelten effekt zum einen treiben
wir die modernisierung unserer
wirtschaft und des mittelstandes voran
und zum anderen kann es gelingen die
jetzt gegen da sich beklagenswert
geringe wachstumsraten unseres landes zu
erhöhen und ich glaube dass das ein
angebot ist das wenn man die
unterschiedlichen dinge miteinander
verbinden will auf den tisch gehört herr
linder will keine
koalitionsverhandlungen zumindest nicht
hier und jetzt hören frau berg ich
versuch's jetzt mal bei ihnen wären sie
denn bereit die schuldenbremse zu
akzeptieren um beispielsweise union und
fdp entgegen zu kommen naja schwer
akzeptieren die schuldenbremse nicht nur
versteht ja in unserer verfassung wir
haben deutlich gemacht dass wenn man die
großen zukunftsaufgaben unseres landes
angehen will dann kann man nicht einfach
davon reden irgendwie muss man überall
das internet verlegt werden und
irgendwie brauchen wir auch
klimaneutralität sondern wir brauchen
massive investitionen in unserem land
wir haben investitionsrückstau in den
kommunen von über 140 milliarden euro
und deswegen ist unser vorschlag die
schuldenbremse zu erweitern durch eine
investitions regel damit wir diese
investition in die zukunft des landes
auch wirklich stemmen können nur weil
das jetzt klingt jetzt so ein bisschen
wie ein paar sagte ja ich meine politik
ist kein basar natürlich muss man in
einer demokratie immer kompromisse
machen sonst hätte hier einer 50 prozent
mehrheit und könnte sein gesamtes
programm umsetzen so funktioniert das
aber nicht die entscheidende frage ist
doch was sind die großen zukunftsthemen
dieses landes klimaschutz soziale
gerechtigkeit kinder und jugendliche
endlich in den mittelpunkt zu stellen
und eine europäische verantwortung und
diese ziele die müssen in der nächsten
bundesregierung angegangen und welche
mittel bis dahin braucht das ist ja gut
wenn jetzt zum beispiel eine andere
partei sagt wir wissen auch stadtnah
solar vielleicht machen wir ein solar
sonder ausschreibungs programm es geht
ja nicht um die mittel sondern es geht
um das ziel was am ende erreicht werden
muss und wenn wir diese ziele erreichen
das ist die verantwortung die
demokratische parteien tragen jetzt
deutschland zu erneuern und darüber
müssen jetzt ernsthaft gespräche geführt
werden da gerade bei der klimafrage
rennt uns die zeit massiv davon belastet
dass wir jetzt so ein mini
regierungsprogramm also wir führen keine
koalitionsverhandlungen aber an dem was
frau berbalk jetzt skizziert hat in
wenigen worten gibt es da etwas wo sie
sagen kommt mit mir nicht in frage
weil wir aber gerade geschrieben hat
das finde ich sehr hilfreich dass man
einfach mal sagt was wollen wir denn
jetzt eigentlich erreichen wenn wir
wollen dass die solarenergie ausgebaut
wird hatten wir das angebot das wir für
alle flächen ein kreditprogramm der kfw
machen wo man zu null zinsen
photovoltaik machen muss die fdp hat
gerade einen vorschlag gemacht wo sie
anreize setzen will dass es vorangeht
und die grünen hatten für jedes neue
einfamilienhaus oder für jedes haus eine
pflicht das sind zwei unterschiedliche
wege das ziel ist aber das gleiche und
das ist ja jetzt die aufgabe vor der wir
stehen dass wir erst jetzt vielleicht
mal wirklich in sachlichkeit definieren
was muss passieren in den nächsten
jahren frau berg hat gesagt sie braucht
massive investitionen und die klimaziele
zu erreichen sie wollen steuersenkungen
ist das vor allem ein wir
natürlich brauchen wir massive
investitionen ist auch klar es steht bei
uns im wahlprogramm drin wir glauben nur
dass man zu mehr steuereinnahmen kommt
indem man jetzt nach der pandemie einen
fesseln wegnimmt für die die investieren
sollen da anreize geben und wir glauben
dass wenn die wirtschaft wieder
anspringt wir mehr steuereinnahmen haben
als wenn sie jetzt ausgerechnet die
bestrafen
ja die ja investieren sollen das war
denn die sense im wahlkampf dass
investitionen erforderlich sind steht
völlig außer frage deshalb glaube ich
dass jetzt
der zeitpunkt da ist
die soziale frage da würde ich übrigens
ihnen widersprechen dass diese koalition
oder diese beiden unionsparteien nicht
für soziale frage stehen viele
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
wählen die union gerade auch wegen der
sozialen frage und wenn wir
arbeitslosigkeit niedrig haben und neue
arbeitsplätze schaffen ist das die
größte antwort auf die soziale frage als
vieles von dem was die linke vor trägt
also das ziel muss es sein zu
wirtschaftlichem wachstum zu kommen
dieses muss ökologisch dieses muss
nachhaltig sein und die investitionen
die erforderlich sind sind zurecht
beschrieben war soja scholz jetzt kommen
noch einmal zu ihnen steuererhöhungen
sind sabotage am aufschwung hat
christian lindner gesagt und
steuersenkungen gefordert wenn sie ihn
ins boot in einer koalition holen wollen
wo machen sie dann zugeständnisse
hier wird nicht verhandelt hat herr
lindner gesagt hat frau baerbock gesagt
das ist auch richtig so das würde sich
nicht gehören
wir müssen jetzt mit unseren jeweiligen
parteien sprechen über das was demnächst
ansteht und dann finde ich nur geht es
darum dass wir immer zwei kriterien
beachten das erste ist muss sich in
einer regierung jeder jede partei mit
ihren wählerinnen und wählern
wiederfinden denn da haben wir welche
die stimme abgegeben weil sie bestimmte
vorstellungen damit verbunden haben und
gleichzeitig muss es so sein dass ein
realer fortschritt für unser land
zustande kommt und dass die
erwartungshaltung die damit verbunden
sind auch erfüllt werden das geht schon
darum dass wir hier wirklich etwas
voranbringen für deutschland ich habe
das gesagt die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes ist die
wichtigste aufgabe die wir jetzt
zustande bringen müssen uns haben wir in
zehn 20 30 jahren keine guten
arbeitsplätze mehr und schauen dem
wohlstand auf anderen kontinenten
traurig zu das kann ich nicht
akzeptieren dass wir das keine das immer
ein wichtiger punkt sein und ich finde
dass es auch ganz real darum geht dass
wir den menschengemachten klimawandel
aufhalten für mich ist das etwas wo wir
werden das tri politik reden müssen und
wie wir das möglich machen können es
geht im übrigen über um überwiegend
privatwirtschaftliche investitionen wie
wir in dieser runde und anderenorts auch
schon diskutiert haben da braucht es
also gar kein öffentliches geld zu aller
erst und das muss möglich gemacht werden
dass diese dinge zustande komme aber es
muss die große bewegung ermöglicht
werden das wäre ein modernes
industrieland das gleichzeitig
klimaschutz betreibt werden und für mich
spielt natürlich die frage des respekts
in unserer gesellschaft eine große rolle
es kann nicht so sein dass ein teil der
bürger naumburger das geführt da kommt
eine gute zukunft aber sie haben nichts
davon und sie sind nicht dabei wir
müssen das was jetzt in der kroner krise
auch an anerkennung für die
lebensleistung und berufliche leistungen
vieler bürgern und bürger sichtbar
geworden ist das müssen wir auch nach
der korona deshalb als aufrechter nicht
verdaut die große bewegung ist das eine
aber die leute wollen natürlich wissen
mit welcher regierung sie möglicherweise
mehr geld in der tasche haben mit
welcher regierung es ihnen besser geht
ja die vorschläge die ich dazu habe habe
ich ja jetzt ein paar wochen und monate
immer vorgetragen wie das genau so
funktionieren kann und jetzt muss
miteinander gesprochen werden das ist
doch richtig und ich finde was ist das
verwunderliche das verwunderliche ist
nicht dass drei parteien eine regierung
bilden werden müssen sondern das was ich
gut hinkriegen will ist dass es schnell
geht schnell geht es
gehören inhalte dazu auch wenn wir nicht
verhandeln wollen ein jamaika bündnis
das auf ihrer seite sozusagen dann
angestrebt wird zusammen mit den grünen
könnte vor der frage stehen ende des
verbrennungsmotors
sehen sie da spielräume die grünen
wollen keine neuzulassung mehr ab 2030
wer die internationale automobil
ausstellung gesehen hat jetzt bei uns in
münchen stattgefunden hat merkt wie weit
die industrie an der stelle schon ist
ich kann mir vorstellen 2030 halte ich
für nicht machbar dass es gibt zu viele
brüche aber 2035 das ende eines fossilen
verbrennungsmotors ist durchaus denkbar
wären wir noch synthetische kraftstoffe
so dass da gäbe es sicherlich
möglichkeiten allerdings müssen wir dazu
auch enorm voran kommen mit technologie
mit elektromobilität bei einer die
meisten elektro ladepunkte in
deutschland von allen bundesländern wir
bräuchten tatsächlich große wasserstoff
initiative noch dazu und vor allem auch
die förderung synthetischer kraftstoffe
das glaube ich was dabei entscheiden ist
man darf nicht nur über irgendwelche
verbote reden oder zieldaten sondern man
muss auch die technologie voranbringen
ich glaube dass entscheidend ist das ist
auch bisschen so der unterschied vom
ansatz her zu unseren ökologischen ideen
dass wir nicht nur ausschließlich auf
ein gesetzliches verbot von etwas
schauen sondern auf angebot auf andere
veränderungen aber ich glaube schon dass
wir da viel erreichen könnt also ich
habe verband man sich 40 die
klimaneutralität als ziel ausgeben wir
investieren allein in bayern nur für ein
bundesland eine milliarde euro und da
gibt es viele die in wie wir ökologische
ökonomische leistungsfähigkeit
zusammenbringen und das scheint mir ganz
entscheidend wenn ich das noch sein darf
in dem wir auch das gesamte land
mitnehmen bei dieser frage es reicht
nicht die sozusagen die städtischen
eliten dabei mitzunehmen sondern auch
die ländliche räume nun bei uns zum
beispiel auch ganz wichtig dass wir für
steigende energiepreise einen ausgleich
finden zb durch eine erhöhung der
pendlerpauschale
vorherigen erste analysen der
wählerwanderung sagen sie haben viele
stimmen an die spd verloren wird es da
nicht langsam zeit ihre positionen
beispielsweise zur nato zu den usa mal
grundsätzlich zu überdenken vielleicht
sogar über bord zu werfen
vielleicht sollten wir an unserer
haltung gegenüber der nato und der außen
und sicherheitspolitik überdenken
afghanistan hat gezeigt was das
sogenannte nation building macht was
internistische interventionistische
eingriffe der bundeswehr beziehungsweise
der nato von bringen bin ich gar nichts
und ich glaube schon breiten macht
gerade einen besseren job als wir das
hier in deutschland tun wenn ich darüber
nachzudenken wie wir zur entspannungs
politikum wie wir ein bündnis bilden
können was friedenspolitik tatsächlich
in den mittelpunkt stellt obwohl es am
abrüstung geht wo es um
entwicklungszusammenarbeit geht aber
nicht um weitere konfrontationen und
insofern die wählerwanderung zur spd
erklärt sich ziemlich deutlich die
polarisierung zwischen den beiden
kanzlerkandidaten nacht und scholz und
da auch meine erfahrung an straßen
wahlkämpferin ist sehr eindeutig dass
die menschen rot grün wollten deswegen
oder falls gewählt haben
das wäre natürlich aus unserer sicht
besser gewesen hätten sich für die linke
entschieden aber dennoch ist es
natürlich aus der polarisierung sehr
deutlich zu erklären vorbei sie sind
nicht mehr stärkste oppositionsfraktion
sie werden nicht mehr direkt hinter dem
bundeskanzler wer auch immer es wird
sprechen sie haben auch wichtige
ausschüsse verloren den
haushaltsausschuss zum beispiel wie
werden sie darauf reagieren das ist
jetzt im deutschen bundestag für sie
schwieriger wird
also es wird nicht schwieriger also
grundsätzlich ist es so dass der
haushaltsausschuss in der tat der
stärksten oppositionskraft zufällt das
sind wir vier jahre lang gewesen
die stärkste oppositionsfraktion diesen
status werden wir in der tat verlieren
eben auch weil sich das parteiengefüge
durch die durch die wahlergebnisse
verschieben wird ganz klar wir werden
weiter machen wie bisher mit einer
konstruktiven guten oppositionsarbeit
schauen sie wir haben als afd das
instrumentarium der namentlichen
abstimmungen haben wir sehr stark
genutzt das in jedem wahlkreis die
abgeordneten getestet geprüft werden
konnten von den wählern vor ort wie sie
in elementaren fragen abgestimmt haben
das wäre ohne die afd gar nicht möglich
gewesen ich glaube ich muss auch nicht
ich muss auch nicht
weiter es ist schon wahr liebe frau
baerbock wir haben sehr viele
namentlichen abstimmungen eben auch
beantragt und ich glaube auch dass es
letztendlich muss es einfach so sagen
der cdu csu auf die füße gefallen ist
wie wir jetzt heute abend auch sehen
nach 16 jahren kanzlerschaft merkel weiß
die bundesrepublik heute abend
eigentlich nur dass ihre regierungszeit
zu ende ist wer mit wem regieren wird
und wieder weg dorthin aussieht ist auch
jetzt drei stunden nach schließung der
wahllokale
völlig offen deshalb jetzt unsere
schlussrunde zum weiteren vorgehen und
zum zeitplan dabei kommt es
möglicherweise ja auch sehr stolz gehen
sie eigentlich davon aus dass es eine 17
neujahrsansprache von angela merkel
geben wird wird das wieder so lange
dauern wie 2017 oder bescheren sie uns
zu weihnachten oder zum jahreswechsel
eine neue regierung mein ehrgeiz ist
dass wir schneller hinkriegen so dass
frau merkel diese ansprache nicht
nochmal halten muss können sie es genau
sagen was haben sie sich vorgenommen wie
lange darf das dauern ich finde genaues
datum zu nennen wäre absurd aber es muss
schon so sein dass ich dass wir alles
dafür tun dass wir vor weihnachten
fertig sind ein bisschen vorher wer auch
noch gut und das geht auch wenn man
konstruktiv miteinander spricht und
nicht letztendlich die sachen laufen
lässt es geht ja auch darum politische
führung zu zeigen und zu erkennen wo
mögliche kompromisse geschlossen werden
können die nicht nur auf dem papier
funktionieren sondern auch in der
wirklichkeit unseres landes darum geht's
doch wir haben den anspruch
unterstrichen dass auch sie kanzler
werden wollen die viel zeit geben sie
sich selber um zu einer tragfähigen
regierungskonstellation zukommen
unterscheiden zwischen sondierungen und
echten koalitionsgesprächen wie lange
werden die sondierungen brauchen wie
lange wird es dauern bis das land
ungefähr war es ein wirklich weiß in
welche richtung es geht mindestens
formal könnte es länger dauern weil die
lage heute abend so kompliziert ist ich
würde mir wünschen dass wir schneller
sind und einen ganz anderen stil wählen
als bei den letzten malen sondierung
hieß wochenlang in der parlamentarischen
gesellschaft an einzelnen formulierungen
ringen um dann am ende zu irgendeinem
ergebnis zu kommen und dann erst
koalitionsverhandlungen zu beginnen ich
finde dafür haben wir nicht die zeit und
wir haben bei den ganzen letzten wahlen
erlebt dass das thema das die
wahlperiode am ende geprägt hat nicht im
koalitionsvertrag stand 217 haben wir
nicht über pandemien geredet und wir
haben fast zwei jahre inzwischen in
anspruch genommen 213 hat niemand über
eine weltweite flüchtlingskrise geredet
und es war das dominierende thema der
vorletzten wahlperiode und deshalb kommt
drauf an glaube ich das in meinem land
und in der regierung die ich geleitet
habe gesehen
trauen sich die töre zu dass sie wenn
solche krisen aufkommen da gemeinsam
agieren das urlaubsgeld das kann man in
gesprächen sehr schnell bei den
grundfragen klären ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir das schnell hinkriegen
deutschland hat die präsidentschaft der
g 7 im nächsten jahr ein ganz wichtiges
forum der großen industrienationen der
welt und wenn die themen hier alle
beschrieben wurden da eine rolle spielen
sollen muss die neue regierung sehr
zeitnah ins amt kommen und deshalb würde
ich mir wünschen dass wir das schnell
hinkriegen das heißt auch vor
weihnachten ja lieber fall vor
weihnachten vor werber wir wissen ja
heute dass es mit ihrem einzug ins
kanzleramt wohl nichts wird aber jetzt
geht es ja darum mit wem reden die
grünen wie ist der prozess welchen
prozess haben sie dafür werden sie erst
parallel verhandeln und danach ihre
basis entscheiden lassen oder lassen sie
die basis gleich entscheiden mit wem
überhaupt
sondierungsgespräche geführt wird da es
um die sache geht kann man ja ich vorher
entscheiden bevor überhaupt gesprochen
wurde miteinander das wäre ja falsch
herum aber ich meine das war jetzt ein
bisschen er hält was sein chef hat
gesagt hat mit muss mal gucken welche
krisen kommen die große krise und
zugleich die große chance die wir alle
kennen ist die klimakrise und das ist
das leitthema der nächsten
bundesregierung und das ist die basis
für uns für jegliche gespräche und der
auftrag der wählerinnen und wähler ist
an dieser stelle auch wenn wir nicht
ganz zufrieden sind über unser ergebnis
auch sehr klar dafür braucht es grüne in
dieser bundesregierung hat der abend
heute hier auch sehr sehr das heißt um
da möglichst viel zu erreichen
verhandeln sie auch unter umständen sehr
lange
und lassen sich lange handlungen
verhandlungen sind ja kein selbstzweck
sondern auftrag der wählerinnen und
wähler ist und das erwarten die menschen
dort zu recht in unserem land auch nach
den letzten jahren acht jahre große
koalition endlich besser regiert zu
werden und deswegen ist doch der
anspruch die aufgaben unserer zeit
anzugehen und den gerecht zu werden und
ein regierungsprogramm zu formulieren
was die erneuerung unseres landes
endlich angeht das ist jedenfalls die
verantwortung die ich für uns als
demokratische parteien sehen sie haben
uns ja eben schon mal ein bisschen rein
gucken lassen wie das laufen könnte und
haben angekündigt dass es möglicherweise
zunächst einmal gespräche gibt zwischen
den kleineren parteien wie stellen sie
sich das weitere vorgehen wir uns als
bürgerinnen und bürger vorstellen dass
sozusagen herr laschet scholz dann
parallel verhandeln und sie gehen
montags zu ihm und dienstags zu jenem
und das ganze wird dann 14 tage drei
wochen dauern darauf habe ich noch keine
antwort herr frei denn wir können ja nur
von unserer seite ein angebot machen und
andere überlegen wie sie ihre gremien
beteiligen welche prioritäten sie setzen
welche gesprächspartner sie suchen also
ich kann von unserer seite ein angebot
machen das erste angebot ist ich bin wie
alle hier der auffassung wir sollten
schnell zu einer regierungsbildung
kommen armin laschet hat zurecht auf die
g7 präsidentschaft hingewiesen wir haben
dringenden handlungsbedarf in der
wirtschaft aus der klimagesetzgebung
dieses landes ergibt sich auch in dieser
frage ein unmittelbarer handlungsbedarf
und europa wartet darauf dass
deutschland einer regierung bekommt zum
ich habe erfahrungen gemacht 2017 mit
armin laschet war es möglich innerhalb
von vier wochen eine regierung zu bilden
in berlin war es von innerhalb von vier
wochen noch nicht einmal möglich
koalitionsgespräche aufzunehmen sondern
es blieb bei den sondierungen meine
schlussfolgerung daraus ist wenn man
sondiert dann sollten all die wichtigen
punkte direkt auf den tisch sollte nicht
im detail gearbeitet werden sondern sehr
schnell von entscheidern geschaut werden
wo kommt zusammen was ist dieser seite
wichtig war es einer anderen seite wie
ich es wird schon ein bonus
parallelverhandlungen gehen und danach
während ich sagen dass dritte an bei
wochen starten sie das dritte angebot
nochmal ein erstes angebot war schnell
das zweite angebot wahr dass man direkt
bei sondierungen die wesentlichen punkte
bespricht und sich nicht beschleicht und
das dritte angebot ist von unserer seite
grüne müssen entscheiden ob sie es
annehmen wollen ich hab robert habeck
heute in dieser weise allerdings in
medien auch schon wahrgenommen das
vielleicht grüne und fdp die ja die
größte polarisierung hatten die größten
inhaltlichen unter viele waren dass
diese beiden zuerst miteinander sprechen
und schauen wo es gemeinsam grund geben
könnte machen sie damit vielleicht kurze
antwort darauf ist das ein angebot wo
sie sagen ich komme zu ihnen
das hatte ich ja zu beginn dieser
sendung schon gesagt dass es nicht so
sein kann wie in den letzten malen dass
die wahlergebnisse ja auch nicht her
bisher aber noch gar kein wahlsieger
festgestellt und vor allem gibt es jetzt
keine partei gesagt ich habe doppelt so
viel wie alle anderen sondern das klar
ist dass gespräche auch vorab mit
anderen geführt werden damit das
wahlergebnis was jetzt hier deutlich
geworden ist auch entsprechend der
wählerinnen und wähler umgesetzt wird
die g7 präsidentschaft mag er ein grund
für eine schnelle regierungsbildung
seien aber mal ganz unabhängig davon
müssen sie nicht mit blick auf die
landtagswahlen in bayern in zwei jahren
und um ihre machtoptionen zu erhalten
alles daran setzen dass sie in der
regierung sind dass die csu an einer
regierung beteiligt sind es kommt weder
auf g7 allein noch auf die bayerische
landtagswahl zwei spannende gegenpole zu
setzen sondern es kommt darauf an dass
unser land gut regiert wird und die
herausforderungen sind groß und ich
glaube nicht dass wir unendlich lange
zeit haben und wir müssen uns an einigen
stellen einfach auch trauen schritte
voran zu gehen und zwar nicht so kleine
trippelschritte in den kleinsten
gemeinsamen kompromisse zu machen endlos
zu feilen sollte sie einen großen
koalition auch erlebt und immer noch
eine hintertür zu finden sondern schon
ein paar sehr wichtige grundlegende
entscheidungen für unser land zu treffen
und deswegen kommt es am ende darauf an
ob
jetzt gar nicht so sehr das einzelne
thema bearbeitet wird sondern auch
gemeinsame philosophie und verständnis
entwickelt was in diesem land notwendig
ist das das entscheidende und wenn ich
jetzt mal von meiner sicht sage wenn ich
an frau bekam habe ich denke an den
christian lindner armin laschet aber
auch wir sind jetzt auch zu teilen
gemeinsame generation nicht so weit
auseinander aber kann da wirklich etwas
voranbringen man könnte auch eine
grundlegende erneuerung fürs land
voranbringen und nicht wieder sozusagen
in den klassischen schützengräben
stecken bleiben ich bin dafür dass wir
unser land gut regieren das ist das
einzige prioritäre ziel für die menschen
dort laut so rosig ist ihr ergebnis ja
nicht und eine csu die in einer
regierung beteiligt ist hat es doch
sicher leichter als eine csu die in der
opposition ist ja also wir müssen etwas
für die menschen erreichen klar wir
wollen regieren wir wollen regieren
vorherigen wollen sie nicht nur ihr
wiedereinzug in den bundestag steht auf
der kippe sie haben heute auch in
mecklenburg-vorpommern in berlin
deutlich verloren kommt zur enttäuschung
besteht jetzt die gefahr dass die linke
als politische kraft in deutschland
untergeht nein das glaube ich nicht also
die landtagswahlen in mecklenburg
vorpommern sind ja sehr von der stärke
von manuela schwesig geprägt also ich
fast 40 prozent ganz knapp eine
absoluten mehrheit das ist ja durchaus
schon lange also seit langer zeit mal
wieder ein novum auch wenn der
bundesrepublik was berlin angeht da
haben wir auch eine ganz besondere
konstellation auch da gibt es keinen amt
inhaber der noch mal angetreten ist also
auch da würde ich sagen da schau mal was
der abend noch so bringt auch da stehen
ja die endergebnisse noch nicht fest
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen keiner
hier am tisch von den regierenden hat
irgendeine idee wie sie eigentlich
zusammenfinden wollen das sind viele
mutter um nichts aber was darunter liegt
sind ja die großen unterschiede und
einziger faktor in der nähe der burg hat
doch gesagt wenn wir um unsere
infrastruktur investieren wollen sei es
bildung seines gesundheit da jetzt
verkehrswesen da muss man die steuern
bei den vermögenden tatsächlich auch
erhöhen damit wir tatsächlich als staat
diese leistung erfüllen können und das
alles beantworten sie nicht und deswegen
bin ich gespannt wann sie in einer
regierungsbildung kommen wollen frau
weiter die afg hat heute mit ihnen als
spitzenkandidatin ja sagen wir mal nicht
gewonnen eigentlich ein bisschen
verloren vielleicht schaffen sie eine
kurze antwort auf die frage leiden sie
fraktionschefin können sie nach dem
ergebnis an der fraktionsspitze bleiben
ich habe eben schon gesagt dass
bereinigt um die sondereffekte der
freien wähler und der basis wir sogar
über dem ergebnis von zwei sitzen liegen
so und das entscheiden
also
die antwort auf ihre frage ist recht
einfach also das entscheiden erst mal
unsere abgeordneten in der fraktion wir
haben fraktions konstituierung am
mittwoch will oder ob sie mich wohl und
dann wird gewählt und ja na ja ich meine
ich bin ja fraktionsvorsitzender vier
jahre lang sehr erfolgreich auch gewesen
und tino keller hat einen hervorragenden
wahlkampf gemacht und
dementsprechend stellen wir uns am
mittwoch auch zur wahl aber das will
sein wort haben natürlich die
abgeordneten vielen dank und
unsere schluss fragen gehen jetzt an die
beiden die auch nach dem heutigen abend
weiter um das kanzleramt streiten
lasche spätestens übermorgen bei der
fraktionssitzung müssen sie farbe
bekennen treten sie für das amt des
fraktionschefs der union im bundestag an
sozusagen übergangsweise das wäre doch
die voraussetzung dafür dass der traum
des kanzlers nichts wird und dann
könnten sie oppositionsführer seien also
wir haben morgen erstmal den cdu
vorstand und ich habe die absicht die
gespräche der sondierung zu führen aus
dem amt des cdu parteivorsitzenden und
wie will die fraktion aufstellen das
entscheiden wir dann und sie haben heute
abend uns gesagt trotz dieses sehr
schlechten ergebnis für die union für
die cdu wollen sie auch
parteivorsitzender bleiben ja wir wollen
die nächste bundesregierung führen
das soll eine bundesregierung sein wo
wirklich alle die da starten nachdem sie
sich geeinigt haben auch mit lust diese
nächsten jahre gestalten und nicht
dauernd mit verdruss es ist eine eine
aufgabe wozu man den willen aller
braucht und dazu will ich auch
parteivorsitz nach plan herr scholz
ansehen die frage ähnlich sie wollen
kanzler werden das ist aber noch nicht
sicher heute abend wenn das nichts wird
was wird dann aus ihnen
oppositionsführer fraktionschef der spd
und greifen sie nach dem parteivorsitz
nein ich gerade für nicht nach dem
parteivorsitz rolf mützenich ist ein
großartiger fraktionsvorsitzender und
ich möchte kanzler der bundeswehr in
deutschland werden ich habe den umfragen
enormen dass viele bürgerinnen bürger
das auch so sehen dem wahlergebnis
nämlich diese botschaft auch da entnehme
ich sie auch und deshalb wird es eine
aufgabe sein das sich jetzt alles dafür
tun dass eine regierung gebildet wird
die den wunsch der wähler und wähler
auch umsetzt es gibt hier viele parteien
die viele stimmen verloren haben wir es
gibt auch einige die haben ganz schön
gewonnen
meine damen und herren das war heute
abend die berliner runde wir bedanken
uns bei unseren gästen hier rings um den
tisch im alten telegrafenamt in berlin
und natürlich bei ihnen für ihr
interesse und jetzt geht es in den
programmen von ard und zdf weiter mit
hochrechnungen und analysen zu dieser
spannenden wahl einen schönen abend aus
berlin
[Musik]
der internationale stoppen
deutschland hat gewählt was kommt nach
angela merkel ganz herzlich willkommen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zum
internationalen spät shoppen wir wollen
in den nächsten 45 minuten den blick mal
ein bisschen weiter wir wollen mal ins
ausland schauen schauen wie das ausland
auf diese bundestagswahl geguckt hat und
welche erwartungen welche hoffnung
vielleicht auch welche sorgen es gibt
was eine neue regierung angeht und dafür
habe ich spannende gäste hier bei mir
die ich jetzt begrüßen möchte zuerst die
französische journalistin cécile calla
lange zeit haben sie gearbeitet zum
beispiel für limo und jetzt sind sie
freie journalistin und autorin schön
dass sie da sind links an meiner seite
tatjana firowa korrespondentin für
interfax die russische presse agentur
schön dass sie da sind
freier journalist vor allem für die los
angeles times und ralph sina lange
korrespondent in afrika in washington
und vor allem in den letzten jahren der
europa korrespondent im ard studio in
brüssel schön dass sie alle hier sind
bevor wir aber wirklich einsteigen
wollen wir einmal ganz kurz weil sie
lange keine zahlen gesehen haben auf die
neuste hochrechnung schauen damit wir
wissen wo wir gerade stehen
nach dieser hochrechnung kommt die union
auf 24,5 prozent die spd auf 25,9
prozent die afg liegt bei 10,6 die fdp
bei 11,7 die linke bei fünf und die
grünen bei
14,1 dass also die neuesten zahlen das
bedeutet auch wir wissen am ende jetzt
überhaupt noch gar nicht wer in zukunft
deutschland regieren wird in welcher
koalition schon gar nicht was wir aber
auf jeden fall wissen das ist 16 jahre
angela merkel diese ära ist jetzt zu
ende was bedeutet das was haben 16 jahre
angela merkel bedeutet ich würde zuerst
sie fragen r kirschbaum wie haben sich
in 16 jahren angela merkel wie hat sich
das transatlantische verhältnis
verändert
angela merkel wirklich ein bollwerk für
die usa in europa sie war städte in ganz
treue begeisterte partner für die
amerikaner sie war medaille gewinne sie
hat eine rede vor dem kongress gehalten
zugejubelt
vorwurf in den usa ist die decke in die
höhe gestiegen nach der flüchtlingskrise
diese es gibt viele amerikaner die die
lieben diese art von liberale
unterstützung und marco hat wirklich
alle register gezogen für die diese art
von amerikaner mit dieser
flüchtlingskrise
die märkte haben auch institutionen
vietnamesische leute und so anzunehmen
profil amerikaner war merkel dann das
nonplusultra und dann auch in diese
trump seit wann merken natürlich auch
für viele amerikaner die
gegner waren auch merkel war so eine art
hoffnung für die zukunft und ich glaube
diese gerüchte dieses bild gibt dass
barack obama ist extra hierhergekommen
und wenn wir 20 610 um sie zu überreden
noch vier jahren weiter zu machen dass
das glaube ich schon dass das stimmt ja
aber merkel hat so lange gebraucht um 20
17 zu entscheiden vier jahren ich habe
immer gesagt merkel wäre jemand die
wirklich gerne aussteigen würde würden
die leute das nicht schon ein bisschen
früher aus geplant aber wer weiß aber
jetzt ist sie hat es geschafft jetzt ist
die durch und serien ein riesiger ruf in
den usa
erarbeitet und verdient und vor allem
ich fand sie mir persönlich wie sie
diese persönliche draht zur märkte
gehabt hat die reden manchmal würde sie
was zu erzählen wie sie hat gesagt sie
können usa erst sehen denn wenn sie in
rente gingen und sie haben immer gesagt
die vereinigte staaten von amerika hat
das ganze komplette phase immer gesagt
und man spürte dass man sich vorsätzlich
war wirklich ein großer freund von der
merck und ich glaube die nächste die die
beiden regierung hofft nur dass die
nächste deutsche regierung auch so ein
einbau der geso eine eine unterstützung
die werte der usa
frau carla angela merkel hat mehrere
französische präsidenten kommen und
gehen sehen sagt irak hat sie begrüßt
mit handkuss das verhältnis dann bei den
nächsten war so ein bisschen abgekühlte
jetzt emanuel makro wie würden sie das
verhältnis von den beiden beschreiben
also in der tat hat ja mit hier
französische präsidenten gearbeitet also
die menge der chronist der vierte
präsident insofern hat sie ein bisschen
erfahrungen auch mit französischer
politik und sie bleibt so als bild der
stabilität so in frankreich also man hat
damals das sie gewählt wurde 2005 hatte
man ein bisschen befürchtungen ob sie
wirklich tatsächlich so viel machen
würde ob die wirklich eine überzeugen
überzeugt ist von den deutsch
französischen tandems ob sie genauso
viel für europa machen wird und dann mit
der zeit hat man ja gemerkt dass man
trotzdem zum kompromiss kommt und dass
da die deutsch französische achse
funktioniert auch wenn sie nicht mehr zu
dieser kriegsgeneration
gehörte im vergleich zu gerd schröder
zum beispiel und mit dem man in micro
hat sie gut gearbeitet und vor allem
am ende als sie sich zusammen geeinigt
haben viel über diesen wiederaufbau von
der die möglichkeit von gemeinsamer
anleihen
ermöglichte und das war für frankreich
wirklich ein sehr sehr wichtiger schritt
und sehr wichtiger kompromiss
nachdem man den eindruck hatte dass man
sehr viele vorschläge gemacht hat für
europa sie erinnern sie sich bei der
letzten bundestagswahl soll 1070 und
sehr lang wurde
sie richtig bombardiert hat makro mit
vielen vorschläge für reformen in europa
und sie war natürlich konnte erst mal
gar nicht antworten weil es gerade
bundestagwahl gab dann gab es langen
verhandlungen fünf monaten behandlung
und dann war hat sie auch nicht so
richtig so klar sich positioniert bei
den vorschlägen zu werden war auch ein
bisschen
enttäuschung zu spüren in paris aber wie
gesagt also was sie jetzt erreicht haben
in dem letzten jahr machte zumindest
diese palast zu bringen und man war
natürlich sehr nervös jetzt
in der perspektive der bundestagwahl man
man kennt ja man kannte ja sehr gut den
deutschen partner man wusste was möglich
war welcher spielraum und jetzt ist ja
alles noch sehr auf alles offen genau
das stimmt ralph sina das bild das man
zu angela merkel hat das außenpolitische
handeln angeht das ist so ein bisschen
widersprüche es gibt die einen sagen sie
ist die große krisenmanagerin gewesen in
den letzten jahren die die europa auch
vorangetrieben hat und gleichzeitig gibt
es stimmen die sagen sie hat die großen
krisen ausgesetzt ausgesessen und hat am
ende
kompromisse gefunden die aber vor allem
kompromisse sind was ist ihr bild ich
glaube sie ist eine der besten
krisenmanagerin der neuzeit und ich
glaube dass die eu vielleicht schon fast
in den abgrund gefallen wäre wenn es
angela merkel nicht gegeben hätte die eu
hatte extrem viele krisen in den letzten
jahren es gab die eurokrise ist gab die
griechenlandkrise die flüchtlingskrise
und vor allen dingen die korona krise
und gerade weil angela merkel keine
vision von europa hatte wie makro gerade
weil sie so defensiv gerade weil sie so
gegen vergemeinschaftung von schulden
war gegen eurobonds weil die 180 grad
wende die sie gemacht hat eine sensation
und die tatsache dass sie so defensiv
gestartet ist hatte sie glaubwürdig
gemacht im lager der sparsam bei den
niederländern bei den dänen bei den
österreichern die keinen corona
wiederaufbau fonds wollten gerade weil
sie da so glaubwürdig war haben die
ihren schwenk mitgemacht hätte sie die
großen visionen von vornherein gab wie
makro und im figaro und le monde und
adresse wohnen das alles ausgebreitet
hätten sie diese chance verspielt gerade
weil sie so defensiver und rückte sie
mochte und auch kurz nicht gegen sie
irgendwie keinen konnte konnte sie diese
leute mitnehmen und sogar ein viktor
orban dazu bringen den selbsternannten
liberalen demokraten dem krone wieder
auf profis zuzustimmen dem haushalt
zuzustimmen und nicht zu blockieren und
das war eine sensationelle leistung man
muss fairerweise sagen aus dem russland
kästchen olaf scholz war mithin
beteiligt olaf scholz als finanzminister
hat mit bruno lemaire dem französischen
finanzminister nächtelang hier in berlin
gesessen im deutschen finanzministerium
und hat überlegt wie kommen wir von den
eurobonds weg aber trotzdem zu einem
rettungspaket und es war mit scholz der
mittelmeer das ausgedacht hat merkel hat
es dann als kanzlerin durchgesetzt aber
es war im grunde genommen ein bisschen
die situation zwischen den beiden das
ist vielleicht auch mal historisch ganz
richtig aber merkel ist für mich die
frau scheitert der euro scheitert europa
die griechen bleiben im euro gegen
schäuble gegen ihren ehemaligen
finanzminister lässt sich dann doch die
griechen den klassen wirklich wegmarken
gesetzt und ich glaube ohne sie wäre die
eu so ein bisschen natürlich binnenmarkt
aber auch ein chaos klub und so war es
binnenmarkt und merkel bei sie hatte
auch lange gezögert für griechenland
also sie hat lange gewartet bis sie
jetzt letztendlich diesen diese
entscheidung getroffen hat der titel
krieche behalte ich ja richtig sie hat
druck gemacht es ist für ihn schon mit
papandreou 2010 an als sie eine
volksabstimmung machen wollte wenn wenn
du das machst dann wird ihr nichts mehr
mit griechenland hilfen das sagen wir
ganz klar und sie hat was unter druck
gesetzt aber letztlich hat sie vor allen
dingen schäuble wieder standen mit der
unterstützung von juncker und seinem
kabinettschef selber muss man sagen die
auch gesagt haben das geht gar nicht
dass die griechen geben um himmels
willen und in der tat rückblicken wären
die griechen etwas aus dem euro raus und
dann der praxis gekommen es wäre ein
desaster gewesen insofern war diese
konfrontation die merkel auch mit
schäuble durchgezogen hat sie hatten ja
in gewisser weise des avo irrt war
richtig rückblickend betrachtet und für
mich war sie die figur auf dem auf dem
brüsseler parkett und makro konnte diese
visionäre rolle nur spielen weil er
merkel die realistischen an seiner seite
jetzt sehr spannend natürlich auch immer
auch innenpolitisch dann spannende
konstellationen die es da gegeben hat
ich möchte einmal noch den blick weiten
richtung osten frau 4 sowie ich glaube
wenn man hier in dieser runde schaut das
verhältnis dass russland zu deutschland
hatte es könnte man vielleicht einfach
sagen das komplizierteste gewesen lassen
wir den weg dahin war die mir putin und
angela merkel haben ein interessantes
verhältnis zueinander kühl und trotzdem
ja gleichzeitig immer auch so dass es da
weiterhin gespräche gegeben hat dass sie
sich in irgendeiner weise auch
respektiert haben finden sie dass angela
merkel mit wladimir putin richtig
umgegangen in den letzten jahren
ich glaube ich glaube auf jeden fall ist
angela merkel für die russische politik
eine person die man richtig respektiert
und auch nicht nur für die politiker ist
auch in der bevölkerung sehr respektiert
vor allem weil sie natürlich eine frau
ist weil sie schon so lange an der macht
ist ich glaube die russische bürgerinnen
und bürger schätzen auch da sie
über keine wahnsinnig teure häuser
verfügt oder im autos teure autos fährt
das ist auch glaube ich ganz wichtig und
diese beziehung
ist mir einer seite ein bisschen schwer
zu sagen weil ich nie in dem
journalisten pool von wladimir putin
gearbeitet habe deswegen weiß ich nicht
genau wie diese beziehungen zwischen den
beiden gewesen sind aber
2005 als sie zu macht gekommen ist da
bin ich auch habe ich auch mit meinem
journalistisches praktikum an gefangenen
moskau das war auch so meine zeit so zu
sagen ich bin auch dann gekommen als
angela merkel ist natürlich das ganz
leicht gemacht mich nicht
ja und und diese zeit war
für mich gar nicht geprägt dass vor
allem die regierungskonsultationen
regelmäßig stattfanden natürlich in
russland und deutschland
an den natürlich beide frau merkel und
herr putin beteiligt waren und auch so
die für mäßig waren die beziehungen viel
lockerer als vielleicht davor weil es
gab ganz viele touristischen reisen ganz
viele viel austausch miteinander und
natürlich nach dem jahr 2014 das
stichwort ukrainer
christ hat sich die situation vollkommen
geändert und
und jetzt ist man da wo man ist und das
ist ja jetzt schon deutlich kühler als
wir geben das muss man ja sagen also in
den letzten jahren habe ich das gefühl
gehabt wahrscheinlich stimmen mir alle
zu das war ein sehr kaltes verhältnis
wenn auch weiterhin natürlich gespräche
immer geführt worden sind sie sich mal
gefragt ob die blumen die wladimir putin
ihr jetzt am ende überreichte blumen
sind des respekts oder das eigentlich
bin ich froh dass sie weg ist
ich persönlich glaube dass
das doch die blumen das respekt sind
weil ich glaube und das hat er auch
gesagt dass er sehr respektiert ich
meine sie hat immerhin nord stream 2
gegen den willen anderer europäer ja bis
zum schluss verteidigt gegen polen gegen
die baltischen staaten das muss man ja
sehen dass sie russisches gas letztlich
befürwortet hat und dass ich ihre findet
die szene mit dem hund wohin wissen dass
sie diese diese hunde angst hat da sein
was ich labrador oder eine mischung aus
irgendwelchen kampfkandidat haben auf
jeden fall ein sehr großer hohen werte
um diesen raum hinein gehört genau und
ihr doll und er damit einfach deutlich
zeigt wer ist hier der chef und ich weiß
genau wo deine ängste sind
hochinteressant ja ist das denn aus
amerikaner aus amerikanischer sicht so
dass man da auch ein bisschen mit
argwohn geschaut hat wie gut am ende
doch immer weiter der gesprächsfaden
zwischen deutschland und russland war
nein ich glaube das war gut und wichtig
dass er merkel ein dialog mit ihm hatte
und bei dem russisch konnte und vor
allem merkel was ist die konsequenz aus
dem zwei weil sich sehr konsequent mit
den fraktionen und
die friedensverhandlungen in balance und
so das hat sich sehr sehr gut gemacht
und das ist irgendwie der wunsch der
amerikaner dass die deutschen
einführungswoche hier übernehmen kann
und diese regionale probleme die märkte
wirklich in asien die hände alles sofort
zu tun und obama hat diese bunte bild
gemacht und mit china jetzt sieht man
dass die spannungen da wärme und für
washington ist es schön und gut wenn ein
starkes deutschland hier eine
führungsrolle übernehmen kann ich weiß
dass wollte führung in deutschland geht
nicht aber das wohnen das war nicht nur
die narren das wohnen die poren das
wohnen viele leute dass deutschland mehr
merken hat sehr gute führen gezeigt in
der russlands sachen in der in der cream
in der krise die wertekompass war alles
verstehe und habe nord stream zeit zb
sieht amerika ja sehr kritisch bei
navalny konnte sie überhaupt nichts mehr
erreichen genau das ist kritisch weil
ukraine wird dadurch
probleme und die osteuropäer wollen das
nicht und diese diese milliarden an gas
die nach moskau schließt das ist
stabilisieren von moskau das
unterminiert die ganze sanktionen und
die grünen in die grünen in berlin die
wohnort kein dort stehen zwei war das
ist überflüssig und das
verursacht spannungen der eu frankreich
für auto gegen das jeder hat seine
blinde punkte oder aber die amerikaner
haben trotzdem keine sanktionen dann
gegen los den zwei letztlich gemacht aus
respekt vor deutschland das hat sich
auch noch mal interessant das war ja
lange eine diskussion aber dann joe
biden doch gesagt dass dann doch nicht
weil deutschland lässt sich so wichtig
war um and china ist super wichtig und
merkel blockt deutschland als bewunderte
maschine jetzt gibt es aber dieses nicht
wohin er will damit sagen wollte in dem
verhältnis zu russland aber es könnte
man ja auch sagen zu dem verhältnis zu
china ist dass man registriert zwar dass
merkel manchmal schon klar sache bilanz
vor allem wenn es um den menschheits
reichte geht aber das doch wer bereit
ist sehr gut zu kooperieren wenn es um
die wirtschaftsinteressen deutschland
geht also ein mit blick auf china
tatsächlich genau hinblickt also aber
auch russland und china natürlich wo sie
sehr oft gereist ist und und da wünscht
man sich auch
aus französischer beste aber auch auf
glaube ich anderen von anderen nachbarn
dass sie eben das ist nicht nur dabei
bleibt bei einer diploma sie diese fiel
die industriellen interessen bedient sie
haben dass gerade so ein bisschen
gestriffen es gibt ja diese neuen
militärischen absprachen bündnisse jetzt
zum beispiel großbritannien australien
und usa
das verärgert frankreich europa spielt
offensichtlich gar keine rolle hier
entstehen neue bündnisse also das ist
ist das nicht auch ein moment von
schwäche jetzt an dieser stelle zu sehen
angela merkel und deutschland haben
nicht mehr die macht hier jetzt vorne
mit zu reden absolute und ich meine auch
die situation in afghanistan also das
vielzitierte beispiel des flughafens von
kabul wo er nun die eu nicht in der lage
war irgendwie noch zu handeln ohne
stützung der amerikaner noch mal ganz
deutlich gemacht wurde defizit liegt
daran hat auch angela merkel nichts
geändert und in der tat muss europa da
zusammenarbeiten ist der völlige irrsinn
dass man beim betanken von flugzeugen in
kompatible systeme hat das kein
munitions austausch möglich ist et
cetera pp dass wir 27 verschiedene
waffensysteme entwickeln und viel mehr
geld als russland in die rüstung
investieren aber trotzdem militärisch
von stecher sind also diese defizite
sind sicherlich eine herausforderung für
den nachfolger von angela merkel das ist
ganz sicher und ich glaube afghanistan
war noch mal ein ganz großes
ausrufezeichen so geht es nicht weiter
der muss die eu auf jeden fall
handlungsfähiger werden ich finde das
ist genau der punkt an dem man jetzt
sagen kann wo stehen wir denn jetzt auch
nach 16 jahren angela merkel welche
fange ich vielleicht mal mit frankreich
an sie haben das gute verhältnis
beschrieben aber welche offenen
baustellen sind jetzt da was muss aus
französischer sicht jetzt ganz schnell
passieren
ja sie haben das jetzt benannt was
müssen wir machen im bereich
verteidigung der werden die franzosen
sehr stark plädieren vor allem nach
dieser
nach dieser geschichte mit australien
großbritannien und
und und den usa was als schwere diplomat
eine schwere diplomatische krise
ausgelöst hat und das wird auch sehr
laut gedacht was jetzt die zukunft der
nato sein sollte oder wie welche welche
rolle sie einnehmen sollte aber es gibt
auch die frage des stabilitätspakt die
die franzosen und andere länder in
europa wünschen sich eine reform was
wird die nächste bundesregierung darauf
antworten dann bleibt natürlich die
frage des klimawandel weiter sehr
präsent und
und wie dass jemand sich eben
positionieren wird gegenüber das
staatliche beziehungen geben also das
ist da werden auch da wird man ja sehr
sehr stark auch für eine emanzipation
gegenüber den usa das ist ja interessant
ist dicht stabilitätspfad wenn ich das
kurz einfügen darf aus russischer
perspektive das wird die hammer nummer
für den merkel nachfolger
denn bruno lemaire ich darf ich noch mal
ins feld für eine französische
finanzminister hat auf dem letzten
treffen in slowenien jetzt gesagt dass
man auf freunde diese ganzen
stabilitätsregeln das nimmt doch keiner
märz nun also dass sie höchstens 60
prozent des wirtschafts aufkommens als
schulden haben dürfen deutschland hat ja
schon 71 frankreich hat 119 und ganz zu
schweigen von griechenland die über 200
prozent haben und italien die 160 haben
also wohl nur mehr sagt komm lass uns da
lockerer werden und realistischer und
das wird jetzt spannend wie reagieren
darauf ein bundeskanzler laschet oder
ein bundeskanzler scholz wie gehen die
damit umgehen sie in den konflikt mit
frankreich
in den konflikt mit dem club
méditerranée oder schwenken sie ein auf
diese linie lasst uns lockerer mit der
schuldenpolitik und umgehen und den
stabilitätspakt aufweichen das wird
glaube ich eine der das ist der erste
lackmustest in brüssel werden wie
positioniert man sich da und ich glaube
da wird es spannend wer wird der nächste
finanzminister wird dass ein herr
lindner oder wird das eine habe da
könnte es dann in brüssel auch noch mal
unterschiedliche akzentsetzungen geben
worauf ihr so war wie sieht man
eigentlich diese neue bündnisse die hier
gerade angesprochen worden sind dieses
projekt orkus in russland ich glaube
offiziell geäußert hat sich russland
dazu nicht zu diesen militärischen
abkommen die ja sozusagen jenseits der
nato stattfinden
nein noch nicht ich glaube auch noch
nicht aber ich habe heute kurzen
statement von der sprecherin des
russischen außenministeriums gesehen und
es ging so in der richtung dass wie sie
auch schon am anfang eigentlich in ihrer
frage in wie erwähnt haben dass
in russland sieht man das so dass man
dem europäischen union sozusagen
angezeigt hat wer eigentlich da recht
was zu sagen
durch diesen bündnis
ich finde die ja sagen darf die europäer
sind total blaue hier denken das thema
carbon geschäfte von frankreich
wegnehmen gar nicht gefällt die
australien haben jetzt wirklich angst
vor china und die wollen die beste
aber die franzosen haben den preis
verdoppelt und nicht liefern können und
die franzosen könnten nur diese u boote
liefen sie sind zu wenig diese boote in
zehn jahren austria hat zunehmende angst
vor china china markt sanktionen gegen
austria und die wurden die bestmögliche
u-boote und
es ist wirklich ein kalter krieg da in
asien es geht nicht um wirtschaft es
geht um strategie und unpolitische und
sicherheitsfragen nicht nur wirtschaft
es ist nicht so dass plötzlich hatte
ford hat den dir weggenommen
weggeschnappt von push oder so es geht
um eine ganz tolle u-boote nukleare uhr
wurde die 23 monaten unter wasser
bleiben können um diese wurde aus dem 19
jahrhundert die nur ein paar wochen und
werbemittel alliierten geht man schon
anders um und dann sagt ja sondern davor
wenn man schon seit mehreren jahren
verhandelt
frauen mag da in der große geschichte
draus war waren wo der tour stehen
wahrscheinlich und das ist der aktuell
neunter botschaft oder schon so groß
natürlich ein einfaches argument weil er
natürlich gibt wahlkampf in frankreich
in sechs monaten aber trotzdem gibt es
ja gewisse arten wie man mit mit
alliierten zusammen das gar nicht sein
dass probleme und ich sage mal ganz
erprobte abzug ohne die alliierten zu
informieren also sind natürlich jetzt
viele fragen
der hat auch noch mal gezeigt wie gross
setzt sich die entfremdung ist zwischen
den usa und den europäischen alliierten
also einfach die koffer einzupacken und
zu sagen wir gehen ohne vorher zu
überlegen und so ist ist ein
ausrufungszeichen und merkel bin ich
noch mal auf merkel zurück und hat es
schon ganz früh gesagt hat schon vor ich
glaube in irgend einem bierzelt gesagt
wir müssen autonomer werden die klassen
ein schönes und dinge werden mir völlig
richtig ja völlig richtig nur und beiden
trump hat es ohnehin gezeigt aber beiden
zeigt dass letztlich auch völlig legitim
aus seiner sicht dass die europäer sich
emanzipieren müssen und erwachsener
werden müssen das zeigt doch auch das
unterstelle ich jetzt mal auch eben
nicht nur unter einem präsidenten trump
sondern auch unter beiden vor allem
eigene interessen im vordergrund stehen
und wenn das gut funktioniert mit europa
oder mit frankreich als partner
wunderbar aber man fühlt sich da nicht
verpflichtet also offensichtlich nimmt
man dann doch diesen partner nicht so
ernst dass man sagt ich weiß nicht mein
job
rastan vorher in my glaube ich biden als
vize präsident wurde auf afghanistan das
war das hast du lesen und man wusste in
europa sei monate dass das mit von
frankreich in dieser u-boote nicht so
läuft wie gesprochen man kann hier
behaupten ja das ist alles
wirtschaftliche gründe aber ich glaube
dass wirklich nicht ich glaube
sicherheit gehen und stehen vorrangig
meinen fans geld weil es wird es wird
kein die franzosen wären nicht mengen an
arbeitsplätzen dadurch
aber es gibt es geht eher um und im stil
und wie und im umgang mit partnern
eigentlich ja ok entschuldigung ich
[Gelächter]
mag keine große geschichte raus ich
glaube deutschland spielt eine gute
rolle deutschland wurde auch die wohnung
wurde daher kaufen aber die deutsche u
boote könnten anscheinend nicht diese
und nuklearer die franzosen können auch
event von nuklearen das ist was die
astral gewohnt probiere das marler
gruppe zu verstehen unter
sicherheitsaspekten und nicht nur
wirtschaftliche und das ist das problem
mit deutschland und china
deutschland denkt zuviel wirtschaftliche
interesse merkels jedes jahr dahin
geflogen mit wirtschaftsvertreter und
die menschenrechte das ist der größte
handelspartner die in deutschland hat ja
und ich war erschrocken vor einem jahr
habe ich eine umfrage gelesen dass 3 33
prozent der deutschen haben jetzt eine
positive
einstellung gegenüber von nur 36 jährige
gegenüber ok das zugegeben dass man eine
chance sein und ein paar jahre davor war
das 80 prozent positiven gegen die usa 0
15 china ist enorm an popularität
gewonnen hier in deutschland der die
leute ist eingeschlafen erkennen dass
nicht nur eine gefahr dass ist das esse
ich sehe das ähnlich diese gefahr dass
china mit seinen konfuzius instituten
und so genannten bildungseinrichtungen
sich praktisch als alternatives modell
zu etablieren versuchen und ich fand es
irrwitzig aus brüssel an perspektive
dass die größten brocken
bauprojekte brückenbauprojekte der eu
von china realisiert werden dass eine
firma wie strabag aus österreich keine
chance mehr teil staat subventionierte
chinesische unternehmen eu steuergelder
ab 3 und hier das ganz realisieren und
was ich mit großer sorge sehe es in der
tat die abhängigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft von china der meist verkaufte
bmw der welt der 5er in langen den sie
hier in berlin gar nicht kriegen ist das
modell in china und das ist der
meistverkaufte bmw in viele deutsche
autokonzerne finanzieren den umschwung
zu elektromobilität mit dem absatz den
sie in china machen da erwirtschaften
sie das geld daimler baut sogar glaube
ich noch für klassische fossile motoren
und das ist genau die frage wie kriegen
wir das hin dass wir so abhängig sind so
abhängig sind und trotzdem uns sozusagen
nicht kaufen lassen und da glaube ich
dass die nächste bundesregierung an der
ja nun die grünen beteiligt sind
akzentuierte auftreten werden als die
alte das wird auf jeden fall ein anderer
ton werden ob der etwas verändert in
china ob das sind uiguren hilft ist eine
zweite frage aber ich glaube dass dieses
sehr leise treten ein ende haben wird
das wird sicherlich auch ein stückchen
bruch mit der merkel tradition werden
bewusst sein und viele diskussion
innerhalb der großen parteien in
deutschland also bei den beiden bei der
spd sowohl als bei der cdu und den
grünen sowieso aber bei den diesen
beiden partei ist es nicht so dass sie
dass sie einfach nur blauäugig in dem
inneren verhältnis zu china schauen wenn
man wenn man wenn schon hinter den
kulissen auf jeden fall aber man ist
vergleichsweise dezent wenn man sich
vorstellt dass die chinesen sanktionen
gegen eu parlamentarier hingegen reiner
trikot vor der ja sehr engagiert ist der
grüne im eu-parlament in sachen china
den praktisch blocken nicht mehr
reinlassen seite da sieht man wie weit
sie in unsere politik zu retten
versuchen etwas aus eu-sicht wenn ich
das mal sagen dass dringend notwendig
ist dass wir bei ausschreibungen nicht
hingehen und chinesische staatskonzerne
einer solchen digital diktatur diese
aufträge vermitteln mit europäischem
steuergeld sondern die das public
procurement die ausschreibung müssen so
gestaltet werden dass chinesische
staatskonzerne wo zwangsarbeit zugehört
wurde
staatsfinanzierung zu wird sich nicht
mehr bewerben können es muss irgend ein
weg gefunden werden es kann nicht sein
dass man sagt das europäische
wettbewerbsrecht ist nicht für china
zuständig also dürfen sie sich bewerben
also dürfen sie mit ihren
menschenrechtsverachtenden methoden auch
noch unsere steuergelder in der eu bei
projekten realisieren das ist grotesk
jetzt ist es natürlich so sie sprechen
es an was wird passieren wenn die grünen
mit drin sind aber wir sind ja in einer
situation wir haben wir die zahlen eben
gesehen wo wir wahrscheinlich eine sehr
lange zeit haben werden in der nicht
klar ist wer deutschland regiert und in
welcher koalition
das bedeutet übrigens für frankreich
dass es wieder direkt vor der wahl dann
ein solches vakuum geben wird und
frankreich wird lange warten müssen
russland wird ja warten müssen darauf
wer der neue ansprechpartner ist was
glauben sie was ist das dringendste was
da jetzt auch liegen bleibt wenn wir
sagen wir jetzt mal die nächsten drei
monate uns in deutschland damit
beschäftigen werden eine neue regierung
zu finden
was für ross und meinte was bleibt
liegen was die meisten baustellen die so
dringend sind dass es schwierig ist dass
es hier keine regierung geben wird
erstmal also keine regierung wir haben
immer eine regierung aber keine neue
regierung gibt ich glaube ich glaube
jetzt dass tatsächlich die situation so
dass zwei christen partei kräfte zwei
christen politischen kräften sind dann
so sagen wir können desto den exit polls
entsprechend relativ gleichmäßig und
jeder partei oder partei union auch cdu
csu und spd sie wollen jetzt beide also
bei der politischen kräften dann die
regierung bilden ich glaube vor zwei
tage vor 2017 war die situation
vollkommen anders weil da war relativ
klar wer dann diese diesen auftrag
bekommen hat und die frage war einfach
nur weh
werden welche bedingungen dann bei
diesen koalitionsgespräche wer erfüllt
und wenn nicht und hier glaube ich beide
parteien werden versuchen die gespräche
zu führen und wer dann am besten mit wem
verhandelt das jetzt dass er geht die
frage ist sieht sieht russland dieses
vakuum was da jetzt erst mal entsteht
entspannt und sagt einfach wir warten
das ab wir haben es nicht eilig russland
sieht vor allem
kein großes problem oder wahrscheinlich
sogar kein riesengroßes unterschied
zwischen zwei figuren jetzt von laschet
und herr scholz die dass das problem
oder die größte frage jetzt hier
russland ist wie viel
wie viele stimmen dann die grünen haben
werden und man nie so dass angel
annalena baerbock nicht
in ostritz weil sowohl herr scholz wie
auch herr laschet sind ja keine erklären
gegner von nord stream zweiter sondern
ganz zurückhaltend formulieren insofern
können kann russland glaube ich aus dem
neuen film zwei perspektive relativ
relaxt an egal wer es wird die grünen
sind nicht so meter stark geworden die
sind gegner des projekts und scholz und
laschet am beide im grunde genommen in
gewissem sinne ihren frieden mit dem
projekt gemacht ja genau auf jeden fall
und das war auch die frage hört dass in
der berichterstattung
die frage war so von formuliert wie die
grünen dann noch diese beziehungen
zwischen deutschland und russland
verschlechtern
das war unheimlich dass die grünen
angegriffen wurden sind aussagen diese
lösung so wollen die grünen so ein ziel
aus lust an wegen 020 oder was hat muss
dann gegen die grünen zweistellig glaube
ich glaube das sind
sie sprechen mir diese diese fag news
kampagne
ich glaube
da sind vor allem zwei große
themenbereiche 92 und
grundsätzlich die beziehungen zwischen
deutschland und russland weil gewinnen
und treten eher dafür dass die
sanktionen verschärft werden oder
zumindest so heißen bleiben und man geht
nicht auf diesen niemand hier in
deutschland so salopp einen kuschelkurs
so die grünen machen das nicht die
grünen sind auch härter was die ukraine
betrifft also gegenüber russland also
das ist natürlich
frau carla frankreich wird es sich am
schwersten tun wahrscheinlich damit dass
es womöglich jetzt wieder eine längere
zeit ein vakuum gibt oder naja also wie
wir schon besprochen habe es gibt ja
wahlkampf bald in frankreich im april
wird gewählt im mai haben wir womöglich
einen neuen präsident oder präsidentin
je nachdem wie die machtverhältnisse
aussehen
vielleicht kommt noch gibt es noch eine
andere frau die kandidiert kann noch
kommen oder michelle waren hier kommt
noch aber sie haben die
ratspräsidentschaft ist und die
französische laufen
januar 22 22 gibt es frankreich hat die
ratspräsidentschaft inne und da möchte
natürlich manuell micron diese zeit
nutzen um noch einmal zu glänzen braucht
er die deutsch französische achse ja
natürlich weil sonst kann er keine keine
keine reformen erreichen in europa ich
meine natürlich werden französische
wahlen nicht durch die europäische
politik
entschieden aber das ist ja ein 1 1 1 1
t raum wo er sich wo er sich auf jeden
fall gut präsentieren kann auf dem
europäischen parkett das ist zumindest
das was er machen möchte und jetzt weiß
er nicht wann er an ansprechpartner in
berlin bekommt glauben sie
emanuel makro wünscht sich eher armin
laschet oder olaf scholz ich glaube er
kann und er würde unterschiedliche sache
erreichen je nachdem er zwischen den
beiden bekommt also mit armin laschet
könnte ja sicher
gute kompromisse schließen was die
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
betrifft was den stabilitätspakt
betrifft was wir schon erwähnt haben
könnte schwieriger sein verbände wir ein
fdp-minister haben bei dem
finanzministerium in berlin und mit olaf
scholz könnte er wiederum glaube ich
bessere ergebnis erreichen bei über
dieser
haushaltsfragen und
auch ich glaube letztens hat er auch
sich sehr positiv geäußert über diesen
konzept von
strategische autonomie
worauf auch die franzosen sehr sehr
großen wert legen dass es stattfindet
sind frankreich ich habe mich schnell
wenn jemand mit großer freude in brüssel
betrachtet der direkte verhandlungen
geleitet hat und im weise clock is
ticking gesagt hat und waren je träumt
ja auch davon französischer präsident zu
werden und er hat jetzt ein interview
gegeben ist erstmal auf freunde klar
deutsch französische achse super tandem
blablabla aber ich finde es eigentlich
auch ganz witzig wenn wir immer breiter
denken und gesagt wir könnten doch auch
mal zurück mit italien enger
zusammenarbeiten da kommt natürlich
jemand wie mario draghi ins spiel der
aus meiner sicht was die autoritative
ausstrahlung angeht ja extrem stark
dasteht als ehemaliger ezb-chef whatever
it takes und so weiter und so weiter der
italien nach vorne bringt die
wachstumsraten im italienisch
maschinenbau sind gigantisch die korona
bekämpfung die impfung läuft besser als
in deutschland italien steht plötzlich
für seine verhältnisse blenden da wird
eine super autorität das heißt für die
franzosen er öffnet sich ein neuer
partner natürlich lächelt oder scholz
nicht unwichtig aber draghi hat ein
format von dem beide glaube ich nur
träumen kann aber hier sehe er das heißt
bevor wir dann übrigens auch immer
wieder nach amerika schauen müssen das
bedeutet doch dass
es nicht automatisch so zu sagen so ist
dass diese starke führung die unbenommen
angela merkel in europa hatte auch in
den beziehungen zu frankreich hatte es
ist nicht so als würde man einfach nur
warten da kommt jemand neues und diese
rolle ist automatisch für deutschland
vorgesehen sondern dieses vakuum könnte
auch von anderen ländern genutzt werden
zu sagen jetzt möchte ich der die starke
mann frau sein ja also merkel könnte
erst mal könnte natürlich versuchen so
ein bisschen merkels rolle für sich zu
nehmen also sozusagen ihr die krone zu
übernehmen er wird feststellen ohne sie
als begleitung wird es für ihn schwierig
aber man kann sich nach neuen partnern
um gucken und ich glaube man sollte
mario draghi nicht unterschätzen das ist
jemand der auch in richtung
schuldenunion sympathien hat also da die
makro linie fährt die bruno lemaire
linie fährt sozusagen den club med
verstärkt zu nicht italien spanien
portugal frankreich usw da tun sich also
neue potenzielle partner auf und sie
haben völlig recht es ist nicht gesagt
dass herr laschet oder eher scholz jetzt
sozusagen der neue super partner werden
sondern vielleicht wird es wirklich so
eine dreiecksgeschichte auch die sich da
entwickelt
kirschbaum den glauben sie wünscht sich
joe biden lieber ist es eher olaf scholz
oder er armin laschet eine
unionsgeführte regierung lieber weil man
da diesem nato ziel 2 prozent vielleicht
hier kommt
ganz kurz sagen ich aus dem market
respektiert man fragt sich warum haben
die deutsche diese stick mit dem
schuldenbremse und sowohl gebe die
deutschen tischtennis männer aus oder
als die ganze welt gibt das geld aus
meyers die haben aber die deutschen
haben diese diese schwarze nullen in
blut und das
deflationäre
das gerne antworten was ich frage mich
oft ja wen wen mag beiden möchte beiden
ich war natürlich würde ich sagen wir
können mit jeder regierung arbeiten und
die amerikanische präsidenten haben ganz
gut immer gearbeitet könnte über tiefe
regierung in deutschland die die waren
wirklich immer ist transatlantisch
wenig wenig probleme glaube ich aber
trotzdem ist olaf scholz vor beiden
irgendwie aus dem gleichen holz
geschnitten die sind beide mitte in ihre
linke partei die haben progressive
flügel in ihrer parteien und ich sind
ständig mit diesem spannungen sie wollen
die parteien die mitte halten und die
reporter gehen ich kann mir vorstellen
mit ihm ein bier zusammen trinken würden
die können vergleichen was das wie das
ist mit progressive in ihrer partei
umzugehen insofern ich glaube eine
mechanische passieren kann mit beide
mögliche kannst du hier geht was ein
bisschen problematisch ist es die linke
flügel der spd und diese geräusche gegen
nato gegen zwei prozent was diese helm
nütze nichts sagt ab und so dass diese
bundesschnitt deutschland die wurst
version nicht diese amerikanische
kampfflugzeuge diese nukleare teilhabe
wurde die in frage stellen das macht
schon angst und auch die die geräusche
von der linke parteien nato auflösen da
da wird schon nicht über den vorteil ist
dass sie nicht so viel geschrieben haben
in ihrem programm über über verteidigung
verteidigungen ja in dem spd-programm
insofern gibt es noch viele
wirtschaftlich fdp und grünen eher
schwierig werden genau aber ich glaube
urlaub scholz ami laschet unterscheiden
sich da zumindest was diese stärkung der
nato an geht nicht so sehr ich denke
eine mehrheit der deutschen sorgt dafür
dass diese transatlantische bundes
bleibt ich glaube viele viele spd wähler
grüne der die wellen arg enttäuscht wenn
plötzlich die linke in dieser koalition
wählen und diese anti nato kräfte würden
sich ein bisschen verschaukelt fühlen
denke ich ich bin kein deutsche wähler
aber es ist jetzt
viele westdeutsche
haben probleme aber auch dann hätte die
linken in landesregierung das überhaupt
kein problem ich höre dass oft hier in
berlin weil die linken sind weg die sind
praktisch kein thema werden die ringen
um fünf prozent also dieses oder ohne so
roth von daher kann beiden ganz
tiefenentspannt sein mag kann auch die
finanz sein bruder aufmachen denn ich
meine armin laschet hat im liebesbriefe
geschrieben am ende steht hat ja sogar
für seine verhältnisse mutig der faz
einen artikel geschrieben wo er sagt
mensch angela merkel du musst jetzt auch
mal als kanzlerin auf das liebeswerben
von makro an der sorbonne eingehen hat
lassen artikel schreiben da kommt ja gar
keine antwort angela wilms nicht
beantworten und umgekehrt olaf scholz
hat ja diesen corona wiederaufbau von
als blaupause mit geschnitzt also
insofern hat makro mit beiden im grunde
um gute ansprechpartner also da kann er
fast losen wenn er lieber möchte
russland sieht das ähnlich wenn ich sie
verstanden wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe die grünen werden
zumindest keine bundeskanzlerin stellen
und damit wird vladimir putin einfach
abwarten und schauen mit wem er
weiterspricht genauso war es auch heute
sie haben beobachtet und
gesagt dass man erst mal abwarten soll
ich weiß nicht warum aber mich fragt man
die ganze zeit über seine mögliche oder
zumindest gefragt hat über die mögliche
rot rot grüne koalition was glaube ich
davor nicht möglich war und jetzt auch
nicht dass er jetzt ungemein sieht das
so aus als wäre das auch keinen fall
möglich ausgeschlossen und diese
koalition zum beispiel oder diese
möglichkeit war überhaupt nicht
besprochen
russischen medien politik und
wenn wir dann weiter das gespräch
erörtert werden was wäre dann bevorzuge
ich für russland oder der wäre dann
bevorzugt als kanzler ich glaube
gefühlsmäßig natürlich spd und herr
scholz aber mit beiden kanzlerkandidaten
man sprechen können weil sie ganz
passend und sagen wir
verständlich für die russische von
männern geprägte politik sind und weil
sie auch schon über seine erfahrung
verfügen weil sie schon haben als organ
der spd minister gabriel der nordstream
2 auf den weg gebracht haben ja alle
sind schliesslich kriege ich habe auch
das gefühl die würste freuen sich auf es
in spd kanzlerin db vorzogen ja und es
gibt nicht nur gabriel es gibt natürlich
gerhard schröder
und auch ganz viele andere politiker in
spd
unterstützend dann diese diese
gesprächskanäle oder verhandlungen mit
russland im gefühl mäßig mehr als die
politiker von cdu ich glaube was zu
einer grosse nervosität in brüssel ist
das jetzt das ellen lang dauert bis man
sich einigt und das bis tief in die
französische ratspräsidentschaft dauert
das man wirklich eine handlungsfähige
regierung hat das angela merkel als
dauerbrenner immer weiter auftaucht zu
sagen als geschäftsführer der
bundeskanzlerin das wäre extrem super
optimal weil die probleme
flüchtlingskrise haben wir noch gar
nicht darüber gesprochen schuldenkrise
stabilitätspakt ii sind
alles da und da finde ich auch noch mal
ohne jetzt hier zum 3d fans wären aber
nicht mal so ein als entspannend weil
wir hatten ja mit italien das problem
wir hatten salvini der ja die
hilfsorganisation in der extrem
schwierige situation gebracht hat indem
er sie versucht er zu kriminalisieren
als die flüchtlinge im mittelmeer
gerettet haben indem er millionenstrafen
die ihn verhängt hat das ist alles weg
vom tisch seitdem draghi da ist also es
ist wirklich ein anderer geist was die
rettung im mittelmeer angeht natürlich
ist niemand der sein würde kommt her
aber diese art helfer zu kriminalisieren
häfen zu bloggen es ist jetzt so dass
salvini sich vor gericht verantworten
muss wegen unterlassener hilfeleistung
und draghi da einen neuen akzent auch in
der flüchtlingspolitik setz dir
vielleicht auch noch mal eine
initialzündung auf der europäischen
ebene sein könnte ich muss sie leider
unterbrechen an dieser stelle wir sind
nämlich leider schon am ende ich würde
sie ganz kurz bitten als allerletzte
runde wirklich nur im idealfall nur
jahren ein einmal von ihnen ihre meinung
hören glauben sie dass diese
führungsrolle die deutschland in der
welt dann doch hatte nach angela merkel
weiter möglich ist ja so gut es muss
weiter möglich sein ich hoffe dass sie
wirklich wird in europa ja aber ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass andere
akteure stärker werden frau sommer ja
ich glaube ja aber es könnte auch
vorstellbar sein dass hier andere
akteure stärker werden vor allem wenn
ich dann frau carla anschauen freundlich
wo allerdings bayern sind das müssen wir
alles abwarten ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich für diese spannende runde hier
an diesem abend das war schon unser
erster internationaler spät shoppen an
dieser stelle ich danke ihnen liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer auch für
interesse es geht hier jetzt aber direkt
weiter denn da drüben am set da steht
mein kollege madonna moral und der hat
jetzt spannende analysen interviews und
ich vermute die neuesten zahlen ganz
genauso sieht das aus suhler grimm
vielen dank und herzlich willkommen hier
auch aus dem phoenix wahlstudio im
deutschen bundestag die kommenden zwei
wochen das gab mir 22 stunden das kann
ich ihnen versprechen wird es spannend
werden denn wir blicken auf diese wahl
und die ergebnisse eines ist klar es
wird nach möglichkeit einen kanzler olaf
scholz oder einen kanzler armin laschet
geben aber die viel spannende frage ist
wie verhalten sich die königsmacher wir
wollen uns erst mal einen ersten
überblick verschaffen und dann kommen
die analysen für hirscher hat den abend
bis dato einmal für uns zusammengefasst
es wird offiziell auf scholz hat
krawatte angelegt kommt da ein sieger
oder verlierer
wo seit gerhard schröder kein
spd-kanzlerkandidat mehr grund zum
feiern hatte wo nur elend und tränen
standen an wahlabenden wie diesen im
willy brandt haus wird nun olaf scholz
zusammen mit seiner frau vom applaus
getragen und scholz beansprucht die
kanzlerschaft für sich
das wird ein langer wahlabend das ist
sicher aber das ist eben auch sicher
dass viele bürgerinnen bürger ihr kreuz
bei der spd gemacht haben weil sie
wollen dass es einen wechsel in der
region gibt und auch weil sie wollen
dass der nächste kanzler
die spd hat einen weiten weg hinter sich
ein gemeiner clark sie monatelang bei 14
15 prozent mit den fehlern der
konkurrenz legten sie zu jetzt steht
olaf scholz vorne aber hinter ihnen die
die in den sondierungsverhandlungen den
spielraum erhalten könnten saskia esken
und andere die linkere inhalte vertreten
als ihr kanzlerkandidat
magnetismus zuversicht und
geschlossenheit das werden wir auch in
der nächsten zeit zeigen denn darauf
kommt es an und ich bin sicher die
bürgerinnen und bürger werden sich auch
nachträglich über ihre entscheidung
freuen die sie getroffen haben als sie
die spd gewählt haben dass das sprechen
gilt auch
armin laschet beendet seinen wahlkampf
wie ein streckenweise betrieben hat den
wahlschein falsch gefaltet seine
kreuzchen sichtbar ein weiterer fauxpas
verbreitet sich im netz doch der
verkorkste wahlkampf soll vergangenheit
sein armin laschet gesucht seine letzte
chance mit dem historisch schlechtesten
ergebnis für die union in ihrer
geschichte wagte er es noch an das
kanzleramt zu glauben eine
selbsternannte zukunft koalition
schmieden der wahlkampf ist vorbei jetzt
geht es um 1 eine stabile koalition für
ein starkes und modernes deutschland und
bundeskanzler wird der dem es gelingt
gegensätze zu verbinden und ein gutes
gemeinsames programm für die nächsten
vier jahre zu entwickeln
dieses manöver dass laschet als nummer 2
platz eins beansprucht wollte die csu in
den vergangenen tagen nicht mehr tragen
heute abend tut sie es plötzlich doch
wir glauben fest an die idee eines
jamaika bündnis ist das wäre eine der
großen optionen dabei ist aber auch klar
dass das kein selbstläufer
alle müssen dann raus aus ihrer
komfortzone es kann keine lupenreine
parteipolitik gemacht werden sondern es
muss ein bündnis der vernunft sein in
diesen schweren zeiten
olaf scholz könnte sich noch ein bier
bevor in den wahlabend zur berliner
runde und allerlei interviews weiter
zieht er kennt die geschichtsbücher
schon vor ihm wurden männer nicht
kanzler obwohl sie im ergebnis vorne
lagen die wahl ist zu ende der kampf
noch lange nicht
ja ein spannender abend der uns hier
noch bevorsteht wenn die große frage
wird sein mit wie viel abstand unter
umständen cdu und spd auseinanderliegen
und dann gibt es da noch eine ganze
menge mehr worüber sich lohnt zu reden
das machen wir heute den ganzen abend
und zwar mit thorsten faas erst politik
wissenschaftler der freien universität
berlin und wir werden jetzt die nächsten
zwei stunden mal sehr genau darauf
gucken was da sich noch entwickelt wir
haben die ersten bilder von den
wahlpartys gesehen für sie sicher auch
ein spannender abend als beobachter was
war für sie das überraschendste moment
dieses abends bis jetzt naja die
koalitions lage die jedoch sehr sehr
unübersichtlich war vorher nie hat sich
eigentlich sehr stark sortiert jetzt wir
reden nur noch über zwei
koalitionsmodelle jamaika auf der einen
seite die ampel auf der anderen seite
die groko schlimmer da noch so ein
bisschen im hintergrund aber wir
sprachen von fünf sechs modellen im
vorfeld da sind wir jetzt schon runter
auf zwei und das finde ich doch sehr
bemerkenswert hat der wähler klartext
gesprochen hat man sagen also die
möglichkeit liegt auf dem tisch eine
ampel oder eben jamaica wir werden viel
zeit haben das auch in allen einzelnen
daher zu sezieren aber jetzt mit dem
ersten eindruck von ihnen was wird denn
am wahrscheinlichsten denn jetzt kommt
es ja vor allen dingen auf die
königsmacher an sprich fdp und grüne ja
das ist tatsächlich spannend zu hören
wie da jedes wort gewählt wird von
seiten der grünen haben wir doch relativ
großer offenheit gehört gerade robert
habeck hat auf seine erfahrungen auch in
schleswig-holstein verwiesen wie es ihm
dort gelungen ist das jamaika-bündnis zu
installieren die situation ist sicher
nicht vergleichbar weil es war trotzdem
ein starkes signal von seiten der fdp
bin ich gespannt wie sehr man doch diese
jamaika vorliebe immer wieder betonen
wird oder ob es dort nicht auch von
seiten derer die eine ampel präferenz
haben die gibt es ja durchaus wie laut
die sich äußern werden also da kommt es
jetzt wirklich auf jedes wort an erstmal
sind die beiden gleich wahrscheinlich es
gibt überhaupt keinen prüfe diejenige
koalition die größer ist in der die
stärkste fraktion ist im vorfeld hat man
den abstand durchaus aufgeladenen
symbolisch insofern wird man sich auch
bei wer genau hinschauen sie haben es
gesagt wie groß der abstand zwischen spd
und union am ende sein wird der sie zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt werden vielleicht
noch ein bisschen genauer auf die zahlen
gucken ziemlich schmal aus für olaf
scholz wird das ja dann durchaus auch
nicht ganz so einfach zu sagen okay es
war extrem dazugewonnen und durchaus
nicht ein klares statement auch setzen
können mit diesem wahlergebnis aber eben
doch nicht so viel wie in den
voraussagen vorher in den einzelnen
projektionen dann doch für die spd
nachher wirklich in die wallonen
gewandert ist ja absolut die union hat
sich stabilisiert auf der zielgerade hat
sogar zu den tiefständen die wir vor
einigen wochen erlebt haben wirklich
noch mal dazu gewonnen auf der
zielgerade haben sich offenkundig doch
einige frühere unionswähler nochmal
besonderen ihr kreuz dort gemacht von
seiten der spd wird man auf die direkte
frage verweisen bei denen schuld bei der
scholz eben doch sehr sehr deutlich vor
armin laschet liegt dafür kann man sich
letztlich nichts kaufen in harter
währung aber es ist natürlich trotz
trotzdem etwas was man im falle einer
laschet regierung verkaufen müsste warum
man eigentlich jetzt ihn als kanzler hat
wo doch viele ausweislich von umfang
vorher eigentlich wie bei olaf scholz
gehabt hätten großer verlierer armin
laschet mit einem historisch schlechten
ergebnis hat die union nach den jetzigen
umfragen bei etwas mehr als 25 prozent
abgeschrieben wir gucken gleich auf die
zahlen da gab es ja im vorfeld fast
schon die sorge dass heute abend unter
an unter umständen auch ist zu einem
rücktritt kommen kann zumindest aber zu
rücktrittsforderungen das ist jetzt aber
ausgeblieben und armin laschet der hat
ja hier in seinem statement nochmal
klargemacht er reklamiert aus diesem
wahlergebnis auch einen
regierungsauftrag ja absolut wir haben
einen durchaus typischen armin laschet
heute abend erlebt durchaus kämpferisch
aber auch betonen dass er integrieren
kann dass er auch in end nordrhein
westfalen verschiedene richtungen
zusammen holen kann und der einfach auch
nehmerqualitäten hat also wir haben ihn
heute eigentlich sehr kämpferisch erlebt
so kämpferischen ihn vielleicht die ein
oder andere fraktion aus der cdu im
wahlkampf gerne erlebt er muss jetzt
auch kämpfen aber er versammelt damit
natürlich auch die partei hinter sich
und das ist natürlich ein wichtiger
punkt wir merken einfach auch an der
stelle zwar ist der wahlkampf vorbei
aber die regierungsbildung ist noch
nicht vorbei
und auch da gilt es natürlich aus sicht
der parteien geschlossen zu agieren die
eigenen leute nicht zu schwächen das
kommt armin laschet jetzt tatsächlich zu
nutzen was war denn für sie wenn man
noch mal so ein bisschen die großen
linien sieht vor allen dingen dann auch
ausschlaggebend für dieses wahlergebnis
und vielleicht nehmen wir auch im fokus
das durchaus sehr gute ergebnis für die
grünen die hier zu wechseln auch
erhalten haben bei dieser wahl mit 14,3
prozent sagt die ard hochrechnung letzte
plus 5,4 prozent aber dennoch klar das
ziel nicht erreicht und ins kanzleramt
einzuziehen nein das hat man sehr
deutlich verfehlt das schöne aussicht
der parteien bei all dieser volatilität
von umfrageergebnissen ist das jetzt für
alle was dabei ist wo sie sagen können
im vergleich dazu haben wir endlich doch
ganz gut abgeschnitten aber trotzdem für
die grünen die ja von platz eins
ausgehend in diesem wahlkampf gestartet
sind ist das ein enttäuschendes ergebnis
trotz eines eigentlich auch thematisch
günstigen umfeldes die wenn man sich
umfragen anschaut steht das thema
klimaschutz umwelt energiewende
eigentlich auf platz 1 der agenda
insofern war die ausgangslage günstig
man hat trotzdem nicht geschafft das
wird man wie sagt man immer so schön
sehr sehr genau analysieren internen und
man darf gespannt sein welche schlüsse
man daraus ziehen meistens wenn man das
genaue herkunft an diesem wahlabend
nennen wir sprechen gleichwohl weit
gleich weiter herr fans blicken aber
hier von uns und zwar direkt in das ard
wahlstudio das ist ein sprung nur von
hier bei uns ist jetzt jörg schönenborn
herr schönborn sie haben die zahlen für
uns mit blick auf die entwicklungen
bleibt es doch heute abend auch ganz
besonders spannend deshalb wo stehen wir
bei den aktuellen zahlen
ja also wir haben erste wahlkreis
ergebnisse das heißt dass sich die werte
stabilisieren aber es gibt immer noch
wieder kleine verschiebungen die große
auswirkungen haben können ich zeige
ihnen das an der ganz aktuellen
hochrechnung von infratest dimap
zunächst mal für den bundestag da haben
wir vorne bei den beiden großen parteien
jetzt die situation dass 1,6 punkte
unterschied liegen spd 25 9 24 3 das ist
im moment relativ stabil und scheint so
in diese richtung zu laufen klar ist
dass die afg hinter der fdp liegt 10 5
11 5 aber jetzt achtung
die linke schwächelt jetzt doch da sind
wir jetzt bei 4,8 sage ich gleich noch
was zu grüne 14,5 deutlicher sieger die
anderen parteien 8,5 bei der linken gibt
es ja die möglichkeit dass sie mit der
grund mandats klausel also mit drei
direkt gewonnenen man daten auch dann
mit der stärke ihres stimme ergebnis in
den bundestag einziehen kann das ist
aber jetzt alles andere als sicher ob
petra pau die berliner direktmandat holt
es könnte sein dass es dann hier nur
zwei mandate am ende sind also die linke
muss jetzt wirklich den rest des abends
noch zittern das ändert aber nichts
daran dass die beiden diskutierten
optionen jamaika und ampel einen großen
vorteil haben
einen deutlichen vorsprung haben jetzt
passiert gerade was ganz spannendes das
hatte ich auch noch nicht die hoch
rechner sagen nämlich sehen möchten das
mal korrigieren mit der linken sind sich
da doch nicht so sicher und sehen jetzt
zahlen die das ganze wieder auf 5,0
anheben zeigt aber nur wie spannend das
ist und wie hier wirklich mit einzelnen
ergebnissen dann noch verschiebungen
drin sein können jetzt wollte ich aber
etwas anderes zeigen nämlich bei diesen
koalitionen dass nicht nur die parteien
im dilemma sind
sondern auch die wählerinnen und wähler
denn wir haben heute am wahltag in den
wahllokalen in der nachbefragung auch
die bewertung der koalition erfragt es
gibt eigentlich kein bündnis das richtig
gemacht wird am ehesten noch union und
spd oder spd und union
29% ampel jamaika 23 20 das ist sagt man
eine sehr verhaltene bewertung beides
wären regierungen für die kann erst
akklimatisieren muss aber die fdp und
die grünen tun wahrscheinlich gut daran
erst mal miteinander ost zu kegeln wie
sie darauf treten wollen denn die fdp
hat in ihrer anhängerschaft ein klares
pre für jamaika gegenüber der ampel und
bei den wählerinnen und wählern der
grünen ist es kein wunder genau
umgekehrt da ist das 3 für die ampel
gegenüber jamaika also da liegt wirklich
die bruchlinie ich habe auch noch für
den blick in die wählerwanderung die
stärkste partei die wahlgewinnerin spd
ausgesucht da sieht man nämlich deutlich
dass es im grunde zwei wähler ströme
sind die der partei geholfen haben da
ist der große zugewinn von der union 1,4
millionen und der etwas kleinere aber
gemessen an der partei größe deutlichen
zustrom der linken 600.000 stimmen alles
andere ein bisschen verluste an die
grünen ein bisschen zugewinne von der
afg und der fdp spielen vergleichsweise
keine rolle also die spd hat diese wahl
bei den älteren von der union von der
linken kommen den wählerinnen und wähler
gewonnen
sachs war herr schön worden aber auch in
zwei bundesländern wurde gewählt nämlich
in mecklenburg-vorpommern und in berlin
und gerade in berlin da sieht es ja auch
besonders spannend aus
die auszählung ohnehin erst nach der
bundestagswahl stattfindet also insofern
sind wir da was die hochrechnungen
angeht auch noch in einer gewissen
unsicherheit phase aber es stabilisiert
sich jetzt ich baue das mal gleich ganz
auf dass die spd mit 22,2 doch vor den
grünen 20,2 die stärkste partei sein
dürfte cdu 17,4 linke 13 7 afd deutliche
verluste die bisher deutlichsten bei
einer landtagswahl fdp ungefähr konstant
und wenn wir dann in das
abgeordnetenhaus reingucken dann sehen
wir 130 sitze man braucht also 66 um die
mehrheit zu haben regierende
bürgermeisterin oder bürgermeister
wählen zu können spd und grüne hätten
das mit 63 nicht wenn man 66 braucht es
deutet sich also an das in berlin drei
parteien über einkommen müssen ist ja im
moment im senat auch der fall ja und
dann noch der blick nach mecklenburg
vorpommern da sind die ergebnisse in der
tat etwas klarer die spd ist bleibt
stärkste partei wahlgewinnerin hat neun
punkte zugelegt auf im moment 39 7 der
abstand zur nächst stärkeren partei der
afg ist über 20 punkte die cdu
minimalisiert 13,3 bisher schlechtestes
ergebnis in diesem bundesland linke 97
auch mit deutlichen einbußen aber grüne
und fdp können sich freuen weil sie
jetzt wieder in den landtag in
mecklenburg vorpommern einziehen ich
glaube die regierungsbildung könnte
unkompliziert sein weil die regierung
aus spd und cdu ja durchaus signale
gegeben hat dass sie weiter regieren
könnte und das wäre problemlos möglich
geworden war dass dieser ganz herzlichen
dank für diese zahlen sie geben uns eine
ganze menge gesprächsstoff wird hier für
unser gespräch ich sage ganz herzlichen
dank ins ard wahlstudio
und wir blicken direkt zum wahlsieger
zumindest wenn sich die zahlen
konkretisieren und das ist die spd und
im willy-brandt-haus dort ist erhard
scherfer er hat der abstand der scheint
sich auszubauen den die spd gegenüber
der cdu hat allerdings wird das unter
umständen ja dann doch nicht ganz so
einfach daraus einen klaren
regierungsauftrag
abzuleiten man hat sich sicherlich mehr
vorgestellt oder
da hätte man sich natürlich wie immer
das so ist einen deutlicheren vorsprung
über vorstellen können aber die der
regierungsauftrag leitet sich aus sicht
der spd relativ einfach irgendwie aus
diesem wahlergebnis denn zum einen sagt
die spd hier sagen viele mit denen man
hier sprechen konnte in den vergangenen
stunden geht die spd mutmaßlich als
stärkste kraft aus dieser bundestagswahl
hervor auch wenn die stärke oder der
abstand sagen wir mal so zu union nicht
ganz so groß ist wie tatsächlich auch
gewünscht und wieder zwischenzeitlich
zumindest in den umfragen auch gewesen
sind aber zum anderen und auch das wird
hierbei der spd sehr deutlich betont
gibt es einen fluss ein deutliches plus
bei der spd im vergleich zur vergangenen
bundestagswahl das liegt bei um die 5%
55 zwischen 5,5 und 5,3 prozent im
moment und auf der anderen seite sieht
man hier eine union die um 3 8
prozentpunkte verloren hat und aus
diesem einfachen sachverhalt so hasst es
hier bei der spd sei der vorgang
eigentlich relativ einfach dass nämlich
der auftrag der regierungsbildung dann
doch eher bei den sozialdemokraten liegt
nun haben wir in den vergangenen minuten
ja auch deutlich gehört wo die
unwägbarkeiten sind das ist ein
dreierbündnis braucht und dass die
beiden möglichen partner dafür
beziehungsweise die beiden möglichen
partner sich entscheiden müssen auf
welche seite sie sich denn schlagen
wollen also wird es wahrscheinlich doch
ein stellungskampf werden noch in den
kommenden tagen vielleicht sogar wochen
das werden wir sehen wir haben
zusammengefasste reaktionen hier von
ungefähr 19 uhr 19 05 als der
kanzlerkandidat vor die versammelte
menge hier im atrium des
willy-brandt-hauses getreten ist und
gleich direkt im anschluss auch noch ein
paar worte der parteivorsitzenden saskia
esken aber zunächst olaf scholz
sicher aber das ist eben auch sicher
dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger ihr
kreuz bei der spd gemacht haben weil sie
wollen dass es einen wechsel in der
region gibt und auch weil sie wollen
dass der nächste kanzler des landes olaf
scholz
wir haben geworben dafür dass in dieser
gesellschaft wieder mehr respekt
herrscht wir haben uns dafür eingesetzt
dass es gelingt die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes
voranzubringen und wir haben uns dafür
eingesetzt dass es klappt den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten drei große ziele die jetzt
am beginn der 20er jahre von unserem
land zu bewältigen sind ziele für die
wir uns miteinander eingesetzt haben
aber dass das möglich ist dass die
umfrage sich so gut entwickelt haben
dass wir jetzt die ersten hochrechnungen
haben die zeigen die spd kriegt viel
unterstützung von den bürgern und
bürgern das ist ein auftrag dafür zu
sorgen dass all das was in dieser wahl
besprochen wurde und was wir
vorgeschlagen haben auch umgesetzt wird
und wir uns politisch dafür stark machen
an dieser stelle möchte ich auch danke
sagen
danke den bürgern und bürgern die uns
und mir die stimme gegeben haben damit
ein solches wahlergebnis möglich wird
aber ich sage auch als einer von 400.000
mitgliedern der spd danke an all
diejenigen die jeden tag dafür geworben
haben dass das auch jetzt möglich wird
wir sind eine pragmatische partei die
weiß wie man regiert wir sind eine
zuversichtliche partei die dafür sich
einsetzen will dass wir eine bessere
zukunft in deutschland haben aber wir
haben auch gezeigt dass wir das
mitbringen was man braucht wenn man ein
land regieren will nämlich
geschlossenheit die von allen getragen
ist und dass das so war dafür möchte ich
mich auch bedanken
das ist ein historischer moment für die
spd und dieser abends dieser abend
gehört unseren 400.000 mitglieder der
gehörte unseren freundinnen unseren
unterstützerinnen unseren wählerinnen
die diese diesen abend möglich gemacht
haben vielen vielen dank dafür
wir sind gemeinsam
wir sind gemeinsam angetreten diese
partei zu einen die reihen zu schließen
und ich will einfach ganz deutlich sagen
ganz deutlich danke sagen in richtung
von norbert in richtung von lars von
vielen anderen olaf golf die gemeinsam
angepackt haben dass wir heute so
geschlossen dastehen wie selten zuvor
vielen vielen dank dafür
[Applaus]
ich höre nichts mehr
saskia esken war das unter vor olaf
scholz der kanzlerkandidat der betont
hat dass die themen für in denen man mit
denen man im wahlkampf geworben hat
jetzt auch der umsetzung bedürfen weil
das die themen sind die maßgeblich dafür
gewesen sind dass die spd gewählt worden
ist und dann haben wir saskia esken ja
auch gehört die noch mal die
geschlossenheit der spd betont hat in
diesem wahlkampf in diesem mehr als
einem jahr seit der kür von olaf scholz
zum kanzlerkandidaten und das muss man
der spd in der tat auch zugestehen ein
solcher gemeinsinn eine solche
orientierung auf einen möglichen
wahlsieg
hin ist mir zb in den vergangenen zehn
jahren definitiv noch nicht
untergekommen die frage ist wie es nun
weiter geht um unter anderem darüber
habe ich gesprochen mit norbert walter
borjans dem co vorsitzenden der spd herr
walter borjans wir führen dieses
gespräch um 20.15 ungefähr wie ist die
bewertung der bisherigen wahlergebnisse
also es ist ein
unglaublicher erfolg für olaf scholz und
die gesamte spd
wir sind vor einem jahr vor zwei jahren
ungefähr angetreten als wir gesagt haben
wir wollen die große koalition ablösen
wir wollen eine regierung eine
regierungsmehrheit unter führung der spd
mit einem kanzler scholz das haben wir
vor einem jahr schon festgelegt und all
das ist möglich geworden also ich hab im
moment alles andere als irgendeine also
eine an eine beeinträchtigung meines
glücksgefühls heute abend möglich
geworden aber es ist noch nicht sicher
denn auch der konkurrent armin laschet
beansprucht den nächsten
regierungsbildung für sich das ist
eigentlich das eigentliche die
eigentliche nachricht würde ich mal
sagen weil noch vor wenigen tagen die
csu klar gesagt hat wenn sie nicht
erster sind dann gehören sie die
opposition
das war eindeutig gerichtet gegen armin
laschet jetzt sieht man man kann die
macht vielleicht doch erhalten was immer
alles eigentliche elixir sozusagen für
die tätigkeit der konservativen im
parlament gewesen ist ich sagte das
spricht für sich selbst eine partei die
über acht prozent abstürzt die meint
aber weil sie doch noch mit anderen
partnern reagieren er regieren könnte
dass sie das durch bekommen halte ich
für ehrlich wieder ziemlich inakzeptabel
aber das müssen dann auch andere
gesprächspartner entscheiden mit denen
diese mehrheit zustande kommen sie haben
viel politik erfahrungen sind haben auch
viel sondierungs erfahrung wie geht das
denn jetzt in den nächsten sagen wir mal
acht bis zehn bis 14 tagen weiter ich
glaube dass wir vielleicht mal eine ganz
kurze verschnaufpause leisten können
aber nicht lange weil dann muss man mit
anderen
gespräche führen es geht wie wir immer
wissen darum dass jeder an natürlich
viel von seinem programm durchsetzen
möchte und dass man suchen muss gibt es
dafür eine ausreichende schnittmenge die
auch jeder seinen wählerinnen und
wählern vermitteln kann und das ist kein
automatismus für den kann man auch heute
abend nicht lösen das erfordert
gespräche ich glaube aber dass
vernünftige menschen miteinander reden
können müssen aber wie sieht es konkret
aus gibt es schon überlegungen wer wann
mit wem in welcher reihenfolge redet bzw
obwohl hat scholz beziehungsweise sie
und ihre co parteivorsitzende saskia
esken beispielsweise auf die grünen und
auf die fdp zugehen oder wie wird das
aussehen also erstmal bleiben wir so
geschlossen beieinander wie wir das vor
der wahl auch waren und jetzt schon auch
zu zeiten als wir noch nicht auf einen
solchen erfolg zu gesteuert sind und das
gilt natürlich auch für solche gespräche
die werden zwischen parteien geführt
insofern ist das klar dass es die
vorsitzenden und der kanzel
kanzlerkandidat machen werden sicher
auch nicht alleine das kann man sich
auch vorstellen natürlich machen wir uns
überlegungen haben überlegungen im
vorfeld gemacht aber das war jetzt auf
der grundlage des letztendlich
feststehenden ergebnisses und ich sag
jetzt mal auch wirklich einen moment
lang sacken lassen es dann wirklich
entscheiden und nicht über die medien
jetzt ankündigen
norbert walter borjans co
parteivorsitzender der spd norbert
walter borjans der co vorsitzende der
spd ungefähr um viertel nach acht haben
wir dieses gespräch geführt inzwischen
es ist etwas ruhiger geworden hier im
atrium des willy-brandt-hauses aber
draußen im durchgang und auf der seite
des willy brandt hauses wo viele
bierbänke stehen unter eine gute
versorgungslage nach wie vor gegeben ist
da wird gefeiert in diesem moment ein
solches gefühl eine wahl gewonnen zu
haben das gab bei der spd auf
bundestagswahl ebene ja bekanntlich
schon lange nicht mehr und deswegen sind
erst mal alle hier gelöst egal wie das
in den nächsten tagen weiter geht zurück
in unser wahlstudio vielen dank erhard
scherfer ja und die nächsten tage die
werden sicherlich spannend werden und
bei mir ist thorsten faas blicken wir
auf die spd die nach jetzigem
ergebnissen nach den hochrechnungen
diese wahl gewonnen hat olaf scholz wird
sich darüber freuen aber wie sehr kann
er sich über das ergebnis freuen wenn er
unter umständen dann jetzt erstmal eine
koalition schmieden muss und im zweifel
eben auch leer ausgeht nämlich nicht
kanzler wird absolut werden ein
parlamentarisches system da kann man
sich für den status der stärksten
fraktion erst mal vergleichsweise wenig
kaufen und stellt den
bundestagspräsidenten das ist schön aber
das ist eigentlich das einzige was
natürlich an den status der stärksten
fraktion geknüpft ist insofern steht für
die spd weiterhin viel auf dem spiel
denn sie weiß natürlich dass den kanzler
zu stellen dass das sehr sehr wichtig
ist dass damit auch zugewinne für die
zukunft vielleicht verbunden sind also
das bleibt tatsächlich spannend und für
die spd auch noch eine 1 ein erheblicher
grund für nervosität
naja und 5,4 prozent trotzdem stärkeres
ergebnis als beim letzten mal wir werden
gleich noch gelegenheit haben das noch
mal zu vertiefen gehen aber direkt von
hier aus unserem wald studium deutschen
bundestag ins konrad adenauer haus denn
dort ist joachim von fallois und er hat
einen gast aber erstmal gucken wir auf
dieses historische schlechte ergebnis
für die union
trotzdem leitet aber armin laschet
daraus einen regierungsauftrag gehabt
ein rabenschwarzer tag heute für die cdu
nicht nur bei der landtagswahl in
mecklenburg vorpommern und der
abgeordnetenhauswahl hier in berlin
sondern vor allen dingen auch im bund
man kommt von 32,9 prozent und es
verdichtet sich jetzt gegen abend dass
die spd dann doch klar als erster durchs
ziel geht armin laschet der
kanzlerkandidat und parteivorsitzende
der cdu trat heute relativ früh hier vor
die versammelte presse im konrad
adenauer haus zu dem zeitpunkt sei es
noch ein bisschen schöner für die union
aus und wir wollen ihnen das mal zeigen
was er da gesagt hat da hat er
tatsächlich noch daran geglaubt dass er
einen regierungsauftrag aus diesem
ergebnis ableiten könnte
zum ersten mal
seit 16 jahren hat
angela merkel nicht mehr als
bundeskanzlerin
kandidiert das waren 16 gute jahre für
deutschland und deshalb gilt mein erster
dank der bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
für ihre arbeit
aber
und zwar klar
und zwar klar ohne amtsbonus wird dass
ein offener einhard ein enger wahlkampf
und so ist es auch gekommen es ist ein
kopf an kopf rennen dieser wahlabend ist
eine ausnahme situation
wir haben derzeit noch keine gesicherten
endergebnisse keine gesicherten zahlen
aber wir können jetzt schon sagen mit
dem ergebnis können wir nicht zufrieden
sein
und trotzdem der ausgang der wahl ist
noch völlig unklar es wird ein langer
abend und in jedem fall stellt das
wahlergebnis
deutschland die union
alle demokratischen parteien vor große
herausforderungen
wir müssen die weichen stellen für die
zwanziger jahre
das kann keine partei alleine und
deshalb bedarf es jetzt einer großen
kraftanstrengung aller demokratinnen und
demokraten
wir müssen gegensätze überwinden und
deutschland zusammen halten es wird
erstmals
aller voraussicht nach eine
bundesregierung mit drei
bündnispartnern geben können und wir als
union haben von unseren wählerinnen und
wählern einen klaren auftrag erhalten
eine stimme für die union ist eine
stimme gegen eine links geführte
bundesregierung
und deshalb
deshalb werden wir alles daran setzen
eine bundesregierung unter führung der
union zu bilden der in deutschland
deutschland
deutschland braucht jetzt eine zukunfts
koalition die unser land modernisiert
ja so weit also der
cdu-parteivorsitzende da sachen die
zahlen noch etwas besser aus
mittlerweile ist ziemlich klar dass die
spd vorne liegt und eigentlich auch den
regierungsauftrag hat ich begrüße ganz
herzlich heute abend peter altmaier hier
läuft den bundeswirtschaftsminister
herr altmaier sehen sie das anders als
ich oder ist es nicht so dass der
stärkste dann auch zunächst mal die
regierung bilden sollten wir sind wir
sind natürlich alle enttäuscht dass wir
so stark verloren haben vor allen dingen
denken wir auch an all diejenigen
kolleginnen und kollegen die ihre
wahlkreise in folge dieses ereignisses
nicht mehr gewonnen haben aber gezählt
sind die stimmen wenn alle stimmen
gezählt sind das ist demokratie und
deshalb warten wir was der
bundeswahlleiter uns heute nacht
verkünden wird der zweite punkt ist wir
werden jetzt gespräche führen zwischen
allen parteien der demokratischen mitte
über die regierungsbildung und
die spd hat selbst häufig deutlich
gemacht in bund und ländern dass es eben
nicht darauf ankommt wer die stärkste
fraktion ist und dass es darauf ankommt
wer eine koalition zustande bringt die
eine stabile mehrheit im parlament hat
und ein klares programm
helmut kohl hatte einmal 48 6% oder 76
und trotzdem hat helmut schmidt damals
eine koalition gebildet mit der fdp
obwohl die parteien deutlich schwächer
waren ich glaube was wir jetzt erleben
ist dass es eine absage gegeben hat an
eine linke konstellation weil die linke
so schwach geworden ist die leute wollen
keine linke regierung es gibt eine große
wahlbeteiligung das heißt ein riesiges
interesse an politik das ist beides
positiv und jetzt müssen wir zeigen dass
wir über die parteigrenzen hinweg
imstande sind verlässliche politik zu
machen die neuen herausforderungen
anzunehmen
und da sehe ich die cdu csu in einer
vernünftigen position
es gibt nicht wenige auch in ihrer
partei die sagen es wäre zum beispiel
mit herrn söder anders gelaufen sie
haben ja damals auch gesagt lasst uns
söder nehmen mag es letztlich wirklich
an dem kandidaten lag es an einem
einzigen lachen oder wo verorten sie
diesen niedergang ich habe ich habe ja
dann seinerzeit aus meiner meinung
keinen hehl gemacht und keine
mördergrube aus meinem herzen aber ich
finde dass heute abend nicht der
zeitpunkt ist die inhaltlichen und
personellen fehler im einzelnen
aufzuarbeiten wenn man acht prozent in
einer wahl verliert wird man darüber
sprechen müssen was die gründe dafür
waren da gibt es waren analysen die uns
vorliegen werden das werden wir in den
gremien diskutieren aber nicht heute
abend und nicht in den nächsten tagen
wenn es darum geht dass deutschland eine
gute regierung bekommt die imstande ist
dieses land zu führen 16 jahre angela
merkel und dann so eine klatsche heute
übrigens auch in den beiden
bundesländern die heute gewählt haben da
muss doch was passieren bei der cdu es
kann doch nicht so bleiben welche
reaktion schlagen sie voller personeller
art erneuerung wie soll die aussehen zum
einen ist es so dass wir in den letzten
tagen deutlich aufgeholt haben von
ungefähr 20 prozent in umfragen auf
knapp 25 prozent bei den hochrechnungen
jetzt zum anderen ist aber auch deutlich
geworden dass uns viele wählerinnen und
wähler ihre stimmen nicht gegeben haben
insbesondere jüngere die zu den grünen
gegangen sind und insbesondere ältere
die zwei spd gegangen sind damit werden
wir uns beschäftigen wie mit allen
anderen
personellen und inhaltlichen fragen auf
aber eben nicht heute abend ich glaube
der respekt vor dem wählerwillen
gebietet es dass wir zunächst einmal
abwarten bis alle stimmen gezählt sind
und uns dann in ruhe zusammensetzen
armeechef hat ist aber auch schwer
gehabt er musste zwei wahlen bestehen
die märz freunde haben nicht mehr so
richtig für ihn gekämpft im osten
desaströse abschneiden der cdu und dann
markus söder ich habe es nicht für
möglich gehalten dass markus söder
dann so nach tritt wie er es getan hat
waren das nicht auch ursächliche gründe
dafür dass wenn das eigene lager
zerstritten ist sich der bürger sagt
warum soll ich die denn normalen ich
habe eben mit blick auf armin laschet
gesagt dass wir jetzt nicht die stunde
haben für personaldiskussionen
ich sage aber auch mit blick auf markus
söder dass markus söder in den letzten
tagen einen großen beitrag geleistet hat
dass die union diese trendwende
geschafft hat das bayerische ergebnis
ist nicht so schlecht ausgefallen wie in
vielen anderen bundesländern
die union kann nur gewinnen wenn sie
gemeinsam politik macht und gemeinsam
vor die wählerinnen und wähler tritt das
ist die große herausforderung
dass wir deutlich machen das ist mehr
als eine zweckgemeinschaft sondern es
ist eine gemeinschaft die auf werten und
inhalten beruht vielen dank wenn man das
mal in münchen hören würde da warten wir
mal ab was in den nächsten tagen
passiert das war peter altmaier der
bundeswirtschaftsminister und damit gebe
ich zurück zumal einmal vielen dank
joachim von verlor und gesprächsstoff
hier für mich und mein gast thorsten
foster war viel viel analyse dabei jetzt
gerade im gespräch mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister peter altmaier
aber so richtig bin ich raus schlau
geworden bei 8,4 prozent verlusten die
bei dieser bundestagswahl die cdu
eingefahren hat gleichzeitig auch noch
mal der verweis auf ein schlechtes
ergebnis in den landtagswahlen in
mecklenburg vorpommern und auch in
berlin in anderen zeiten werden jetzt
werden jetzt eigentlich schon die
rücktrittsforderungen laut geworden
gegen den parteivorsitz und trotzdem ist
die lage für armin laschet komfortabler
als man es bei diesem ergebnis erwarten
könnte oder ja absolut weil er eben eine
machtperspektive hat das ist eher so ein
schillerndes konzepte an solchen wahl
haben oder auch im vorfeld schon hat man
die oder nicht und er hat sie mit der
jamaika koalition
und insofern hat die union jetzt kein
interesse daran geschwächt in diese
bevorstehenden gespräche zu gehen
trotzdem sind die zahlen natürlich wo so
wie sie sind und je größer vor allem
auch der abstand jetzt zwischen spd und
union wird umso schwieriger wird das
glaube ich diesen anspruch anspruch
aufrecht zu erhalten aber trotzdem
rechnerisch ist die mehrheit da und
daran klammert sich die union jetzt aus
durchaus nachvollziehbaren gründen
blicken wir auf das wahlergebnis noch
mal ein bisschen genauer aus ihrer sicht
woran hat es gelegen war es der kandidat
das falsche programm waren es die punkte
die gerade in den letzten wochen auch
aufgefallen sind das dann doch auch
immer wieder querschüsse aus münchen
kamen von markus söder also in welcher
gemengen lage bewegt sich hier auch
letztendlich ihre analyse des schlechten
wahlergebnisses ja die union ist sicher
keine partei die man sich gerade im
reinen ist man kann jetzt nur ein stück
weit in die vergangenheit gehen dann
sehen wir zwei wahlen um den vorsitz die
beide male super knapp ausgegangen sind
wir haben alle erlebt wie knapp und hart
der kampf zwischen laschet und söder
warum die kanzlerkandidatur da merkt man
einfach das ist keine partei die mit
sich im reinen ist die weiß wo sie hin
will kontinuität merkel oder doch
konservativer werden und das ist dann in
der tat schwierig insbesondere dann wenn
die erzählung die man glaube ich
eigentlich vorgesehen hatte nämlich
fortsetzung der regierungsarbeit
fortsetzung der ära merkel wir können
das schon vertrauen sie uns wenn das
nicht mehr funktioniert dann hätte man
auf den kandidaten oder die themen
setzen müssen beides war schwierig
laschet persönlich wirklich desaströse
werte muss man so sagen ein wirkliches
thema hatte die union auch nicht und
dann wird's schwierig wir holen uns ein
bisschen für das gespräch noch mal die
zahlen run herr phase und blicken auf
eine hochrechnung die uns vorliegt und
zwar vom zdf und demnach liegt die union
hier bei diesen zahlen bei
24,5 prozent die spd bei
25,9 also vor der cdu 10,6 prozent für
die afg die fdp bei 11,7 prozent knapp
fünf prozent für die linke also drin im
bundestag werden gerade eben die zahlen
von der ard da lag das ergebnis knapp
darunter und die grünen mit 14,1 prozent
sonstige parteien 8,2 wir haben darüber
gesprochen wer profitiert hat vor allen
dingen auch unter umständen von 16
jahren angela merkel das war weniger der
kandidat der cdu viel kritisiert worden
ist ja auch der späte einstieg der
bundeskanzlerin in den wahlkampf
gleichzeitig wir wollen aber die spd
noch einmal sprechen hat olaf scholz
eine aufholjagd dann doch auch hingelegt
und gerade bei den werten die für ihn
persönlich und seine eignung als kanzler
gelten da ist er der deutliche mit
abstand der deutliche sieger absolut man
sieht ja häufig diese direktwahl fragen
wen möchten die menschen eigentlich als
kanzler dieses landes haben unter hat
olaf scholz wirklich sehr sehr deutlich
vorne gelegen er hat die drei trainer
gewonnen wo alle umfragen danach
aufgezeigt haben er hat auch in diesen
tree allen beispielsweise überzeugt also
insofern kann er persönlich schon
reklamieren dass das sein erfolg ist
beim insgesamt ein sehr personen
orientierten wahlkampf geführt das kam
ihm und der spd sicherlich zu pass an
der stelle aber auch das thema soziale
gerechtigkeit war durchaus ein dass was
für viele menschen im mit blick auf ihr
eigenes leben ein durchaus wichtiges war
das sah man nicht immer in diesem jahr
an den in den werten was die wichtigsten
themen für das land sind das war
tatsächlich umwelt energie klima aber
für viele menschen im einzelnen was ihr
leben betrifft ist soziale gerechtigkeit
ein wichtiges thema und auch das kann
natürlich am ehesten eine spd bedienen
und damit konnte die spd so scheint es
zumindest punkten in diesem wahlkampf
wir reden gleich weiter und blicken
zunächst aber auf einen weiteren
spielplatz nämlich zu jeanette klag sie
ist bei den grünen und bei den grünen
sieht es so aus dass heute durchaus man
zufrieden sein könnte mit einem
wahlergebnis aber man ist doch hinter
den erwartungen zurückgeblieben das
sieht aber eigentlich nach feierstimmung
auf
heute abend glaube ich gemeinsam nicht
nur jubeln wir sind erstmals angetreten
in dieser bundesrepublik um als führende
kraft dieses land zu gestalten
wir wollten mehr das haben wir nicht
erreicht auch aufgrund eigener fehler zu
beginn des wahlkampfs in der kampagne
eigener fehler von mir aber wir stehen
heute abend auch hier und sagen diesmal
hat es noch nicht gereicht aber wir
haben einen auftrag für die zukunft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
diesen auftrag
diesen auftrag geben wir jetzt diesen
auftrag gehen wir jetzt beherzt an der
abend ist auch noch jung wir gucken was
mit den zahlen so noch passiert wir
haben auftrag nicht nur für zukünftige
generationen sondern man spürt dieses
land braucht eine erneuerung spürt einen
richtigen aufbruch und vor allen dingen
dieses land braucht eine klima regierung
das ist das ergebnis dieser
bundestagswahl und
dafür
[Applaus]
dafür kämpfen wir jetzt weiter mit euch
allen das ist die verantwortung für
unser land robert und ich werden das in
den nächsten tagen gemeinsam dieser
verantwortung gerecht werden und zwar so
wie immer gemeinsam
tatsächlich dieses gemeinsam was
annalena baerbock betont hatte hier bei
ihrem statement so für den von 7 war das
ungefähre haben gemeinsam werden also
robert habeck und sie die auf spitzenduo
wahlen diese gespräche sondierung
die koalitionsgespräche führen
denn es gab schon gerüchte dass
angeblich sozusagen der
verhandlungsführer robert habeck sein
soll also das hat man heute abend nicht
bestätigt bekommen die beiden werden
sich also breit macht und der blick der
gewöhnen tatsächlich denkt geht sehr
schnell und gingen sehr schnell heute
haben nach vorne es gibt ja auch schon
erste signale von seiten der spd von
seiten der union dann auch von seiten
der fdp muss man sagen wie quasi schon
den schulterschluss zu den grünen sorgt
ich konnte sprechen vor ungefähr einer
halben stunde als die musik noch etwas
leiser waren bitten mit der hasselmann
der parlamentarische geschäftsführerin
der bundestagsfraktion die auch mitglied
war im grünen sondierungsteam vor vier
jahren als es um die jamaika fahren
gegen mit britta haßelmann von
gesprächen olaf scholz und armin laschet
eben beide den anspruch auf
regierungsbildung wenn die grünen von
spd und von union parallel eingeladen
werden zu ersten gesprächen wie werden
sie das vorgehen also ich glaube wir
warten jetzt mal die nacht hier ab und
dann werden wir grüne uns morgen früher
in ruhe beraten in unseren gremien wir
wissen für uns wir haben einerseits
natürlich ein starkes ergebnis was viel
viel besser ist als jemals eine ergebnis
was wir erzielt haben aber vielleicht
andererseits haben wir an einer stelle
ein enttäuschendes ergebnis nämlich im
hinblick darauf dass wir führende kraft
sein wollten das kanzleramt den anspruch
haben wir erhoben dass das nicht
erreicht werden kann so von daher ist
das natürlich ein abend auch mit
gemischten gefühlen
und wir wissen aber dass der auftrag da
ist
klimaschutz jetzt endlich in einer
regierung zu verankern und wir werden
gespräche führen mit denen es wirklich
ist es ist aber allerdings tatsächlich
heute abend schon zu hören sowohl von
spd als auch von union da wird schon mal
mit zeiträumen gehandelt in der tat da
wird gesagt bis weihnachten will man mit
den koalitionsgesprächen zu ende sein
gibt es jetzt ein wahres wettrennen hier
um koalitionsgespräche und ist das
sinnvoll also ich halte das nicht für
sinnvoll ja ich glaube heute ist auch so
ein abend wie klage
die zeit der beiden großen volksparteien
ist endgültig zu ende
wir sehen die cdu mit wahnsinnigen
verlusten wir wissen die spd alle bei 20
plus pendeln sich irgendwo ein mitte
zwanzig und
das wird jetzt eine situation sein wo es
vielleicht auch erst mal ein paar tage
braucht wo sich die gremien den der
parteien in ruhe beraten können und wir
wissen doch wir haben die unterstützung
die wir bekommen haben bekommen wegen
der frage des klimaschutzes klima in der
regierung zu fahren kann und das ist
unser auftrag wie gesagt einerseits gut
andererseits enttäuschend und da bewegen
wir uns jetzt dass ich ein klares ziel
für die gespräche die müssen erst mal
losgehen die fdp sucht schon mal den
schulterschluss mit den grünen christian
endter hat gesagt sei doch eine gute
idee wenn auch fdp und grüne erst mal
bilateral gespräche führen wie finden
sie das gute idee es werden sicherlich
sehr viele gespräche geführt werden wenn
man mal weiß wie ist am ende das
ergebnis ja und das da gibt es auch
finde ich so ein faktor zu sagen jetzt
warten wir mal ganz geduldig ab solange
wird es ja auch nicht dauern dann muss
man hier in den gremien selbst erst mal
beraten und dann werden wir sicher mit
allen demokratischen kräften gespräche
führen vor vier jahren stand montagabend
nach der wahl das grüne sondierungsteam
die 514 so haben die grünen sich selbst
genannt sie waren teil davon wann steht
das sondierungsteam diesmal ich gehe
davon aus das heißt ganz zeitnah
beschlossen wir es ist klar wir kriegen
das als team zusammen hin so sind wir in
den wahlkampf gegangen und das drückt
auch unsere stärke aus und da bin ich
ganz zuversichtlich dass diese
entscheidung sehr schnell sehr zeitnah
getroffen werden da sind
[Musik]
er will britta haßelmann habe ich
ungefähr vor einer halben stunde strich
wir nehmen das direkt mit was wir gerade
gehört haben
ich bei mir jetzt immer noch thorsten
faas politik wissenschaftler der freien
universität in berlin wir haben es
gerade gehört da war so eine mischung
dabei bei britta haßelmann von freude
über dieses sehr gute wahlergebnis für
die grünen zumindest man jetzt auf die
hochrechnung natürlich guckt die wir
jetzt derzeit haben aber auf der anderen
seite auch verpasste ziel obwohl das
thema klima ja so wichtig es ist
eigentlich gerade bei den wählern aber
trotzdem haben die grünen hier erfahren
dass die bäume nicht in den himmel
wachsen wollen lag das überhaupt nicht
das ist ein durchaus schwieriges
ergebnis für die grünen will man die
letzten wochen sich anschaut sie kamen
von werten die viel viel höher war der
anspruch formuliert worden auf das
kanzleramt und das ist tatsächlich
meilenweit entfernt heute abend trotz
günstige umfeld das wird man sicherlich
auch nochmal sich in erinnerung rufen
dann landet man sehr schnell einfach bei
der spitzenkandidatur die mit
unglaublicher euphorie gestartetes die
damals auch sehr sehr schnell sehr sehr
hohe beliebtheitswerte erzielt hat aber
sie war eben trotzdem ein
vergleichsweise unbeschriebenes blatt
und als all diese vorwürfe dann kam um
nebeneinkünfte um das buch um den
aufgepeppten lebenslauf das hat ihr
geschadet und in einem sehr
personenzentrierte wahlkampf hat es dann
irgendwann auch den grünen geschadet und
dazu kommt wahlkampf scheint für die
grünen immer eine durchaus schwierige
sache zu sein weil wir jetzt wieder ein
wahlkampf erlebt haben in denen sie eher
nach unten gegangen sind für den grünen
bleibt diese herausforderung aus dem
eigentlich günstigen thematischen umfeld
klimawandel umweltschutz etc dann auch
konkrete politik abzuleiten den menschen
nicht verängstigt sondern die sie dann
trotzdem immer noch unterstützen und das
hat sich wieder einmal als schwierig
erwiesen gleichzeitig werden die grünen
mit sehr hoher wahrscheinlichkeit eine
zukünftige bundesregierung als vorteil
an den zukünftigen bundesregierung sein
es kommt jetzt auf diese genauen
verhandlungen an die jetzt laufen das
ist quatsch im gespräch jetzt auch noch
mal und vor allem in der einordnung von
jeanette klag auch noch mal klar
geworden dass ja durchaus relativ
schnell die grünen unter umständen jetzt
auch ein sondierungsteam aufstellen
werden und vielleicht die erwartungen
sich erfüllt dass fdp und grüne erst
einmal miteinander sprechen um dann an
olaf scholz und an armin laschet
anzutreten zumindest wird es die dinge
vereinfachen oder
grundsätzlich schon das ist ja so eine
charmante idee dass man sagt man ja die
beiden sollen sich eigentlich werden
weil am ende braucht es die beiden keine
frage nur gibt es schnittmengen zwischen
grün und gelb ja aber es gibt auch
deutliche bereiche wo sie sich schwer
tun werden und natürlich ist es auch
nicht egal ob an der spitze dieses gelb
grünen bündnisses dann ein kanzler
scholz oder ein kanzler laschet steht im
gegenteil natürlich wird der kanzler
auch die politik der kommenden vier
jahre prägen trotzdem die beiden grüne
wie fdp können sich eigentlich sehr sehr
sicher sein dass sie dabei sind in der
koalition und insofern ist das natürlich
bei allen schwierigen zahlen die wir für
die grünen sehen dahingehend ein guter
abend für die grünen denn sie wollen
sehr sehr gerne regieren auf das hat man
gerade sehr schön gemein welche rolle
wird jetzt in den verhandlungen vor
allen dingen annalena baerbock als
kanzlerkandidatin spielen oder eben auch
ihr co vorsitzender robert habeck der
heute auch in einem interview ganz klar
auch noch mal darauf hingewiesen und er
hat regierungserfahrung
er hat auch schon jamaika verhandelt in
schleswig holstein gleichzeitig lässt
man sich alle positionen offen was
glauben sie was wir jetzt in den
nächsten tagen erleben werden auch mit
blick auf den grünen länderrat nächstes
wochenende ja die basis ist durchaus
spannend und die basis wird vermutlich
doch er eine präferenz für eine
ampelkoalition haben aber robert habeck
hat heute im mindesten dafür gesorgt
dass die grünen nicht zu eindeutig
positioniert sind im gegenteil
eigentlich hat eine sehr starke analogie
zu schleswig-holstein hergestellt die
trägt nicht an allen stellen würde ich
sagen weil die situation damals in
schleswig-holstein da war es für mich
auch jamaika oder ampel aber es war doch
anders weil die union in deutschland
deutlich vor der spd lag die fdp damals
auch die ampel ausgeschlossen und aber
trotzdem ist war ein interessantes
fremming wasser hier versucht hat das
doch einen deutlichen spin in richtung
jamaika erkennen ließ na ja und jetzt
muss man ganz genau hinhören wieso die
zwischentöne sind aber das ist ja immer
so bei solchen wahlen wir sprechen
gleich weiter thorsten faas wir blicken
aber von hier aus unserem königswall
studium deutschen bundestag jetzt
zunächst zu fdp und zwar dort genauer
gesagt zu meiner kollegin katharina kühn
denn die fdp sie wird mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit damit eigentlich an
100 prozent wahrscheinlichkeit auch in
einer zukünftigen regierung sein und
einer der königs machen
das war ein guter abend für die fdp sie
konnte ihr ergebnis zu 2017 verbessern
hat eines ihrer besten wahlergebnisse in
ihrer geschichte erreicht und ist zum
ersten mal in zwei bundestagswahlen
hintereinander zweistellig geworden das
heißt sie wurde darin bestätigt sich im
wahlkampf nicht auf eine koalition
festzulegen sondern sich als
eigenständiger wahlkampf partner hier zu
präsentieren und diese bestätigung die
mag auch dazu geführt haben dass
parteichef christian lindner in seiner
rede im hans dietrich genscher haus nach
der ersten wahlprognose auch sich einen
seitenhieb auf die union nicht
verkneifen konnte ohne sie allerdings
beim namen zu nennen
die fdp hat eines der besten
wahlergebnisse in ihrer geschichte
erzielt
wir haben eines der besten
wahlergebnisse unserer geschichte
erzielt und zudem sind wir zum ersten
mal bei zwei aufeinanderfolgenden
bundestagswahlen zweistellig geworden
das ist ein großer vertrauensbeweis
parteichef christian lindner im hans
dietrich genscher haus an diesem
heutigen wahlabend und ja wie das
selbstbewusstsein der fdp nun aussehen
wird in den nächsten tagen darüber kann
ich mit marco buschmann entsprechen
guten abend herr buschmann sie sind
mitglied im bundesvorstand haben aber
natürlich auch viel erfahrung gesammelt
als erster parlamentarischer
geschäftsführer in der 19
legislaturperiode
was ist denn jetzt anders als 2017 als
die fdp aus der außerparlamentarischen
opposition kam also es ist natürlich so
dass wir
gezeigt haben dass unsere inhalte nicht
nur vorgeschoben sind sondern dass wir
zu ihnen stehen dass wir unseren
wählerauftrag ernst nehmen und ich denke
dass jetzt die chance besteht in einem
bündnis wie auch immer einen weg zu
finden das alle eine handschrift
hinterlassen das heißt für uns wir
wollen bei der digitalisierung
vorankommen wir wollen die menschen
entlasten wir wollen bei der bildung
dass der bund stärker mithelfen kann
damit für die beste bildung der welt
erreichen und wieder sozialen aufstieg
ermöglichen diesem land wir wollen
aufschließen da zur weltspitze und wenn
wir diesen gemeinsamen
wunsch bei allen erkennen wenn wir uns
darauf punkte einigen können dann bin
ich eigentlich sehr zuversichtlich dass
man ein bündnis schmieden können und was
will denn die fdp diesmal anders machen
als letztes mal bei den
sondierungsgesprächen
also es ist natürlich so wir werden da
sehr fair und offen reingehen wie wird
es beim letzten mal auch schon gemacht
haben aber jeder weiß ja dass es beim
letzten mal so war das eigentlich eine
schwarz-grüne regierung gebildet werden
sollte und wir so ein bisschen beim
bootfahren es gab nicht genug raum für
unsere handschrift und insbesondere
angela merkel hat auch diese ganzen
verhandlung ein bisschen fahrig geführt
wenn ich das so sagen es dauert bei den
anderen was will die fdp anders machen
naja die fdp wird in diese gespräche
reingeben mit ihren inhalten das ist ja
völlig klar wir haben nie einen hehl
daraus gemacht was wir wollen und
darüber wollen wir mit den anderen
konstruktiv sprechen wir wollen dass
deutschland eine regierung der mitte
bekommt und wenn wir eine faire
vereinbarung finden wo alle partner sich
darin wiederfinden können dann ist das
die beste voraussetzung um diese
gespräche auch erfolgreich abzuschließen
sie haben ja vorher gesagt christian
lindner auch viele andere
parteimitglieder das jamaika klarer
favorit ist das ist nun natürlich eine
koalition wo man die grünen
eventuell etwas locken muss wie können
union und fdp die grünen etwas anbieten
das die in diese koalition gehen die nun
wahrscheinlich nicht ihre
wunschkoalition ist also ich finde das
beste wäre erst mal wenn wir respektvoll
miteinander umgehen und nicht vom locken
sprechen wir wollen ja niemanden in eine
falle zerren sondern die gründe müssen
selber sagen was sie wollen darum müssen
wir dann sprechen und hier sollte keiner
irgendwie jemanden hervorlocken ich will
eins sagen die grünen haben acht jahre
darauf hingearbeitet eine schwarz-grüne
regierung zu bilden also dürfte der weg
nach jamaika nicht allzu weit sein das
werden wir dann sehen vielen dank für
das gespräch
soweit marco buschmann mitglied im
bundesvorstand der fdp und das war's
dann hier auch von den liberalen und
damit gebe ich ab zu katja fuchs die bei
der linken ist
bei mir begrüße ich jetzt gregor gysi
herr gysi wie sehr schmerzt dieses
ergebnis unser schmerz das ergebnis es
ja auch desaströs
viele die engagiert gearbeitet haben
sind natürlich dann auch zutiefst
pessimistisch und traurig die muss man
jetzt wieder aufbauen wie wollen sie
denn wieder aufbauen weil ich denke ich
ist relativ schwierig bei 5 prozent bei
der vergangenen bundestagswahlen 9,2 das
ist eine verringerung um die hälfte wie
wollen sie die wieder mobilisieren es
ist so es gibt nach meines erachtens
verschiedene ursachen man soll auch
nicht gleich am ersten abend versuchen
das zu analysieren aber ich würde mal
sagen dass aus thema haben sehr doch ist
sie so spät besetzt das zweite ist dass
uns früher unsere vielfältigkeit genutzt
hat und das ist jetzt vorbei es gibt ja
unterschiedliche standpunkte in unserer
partei und wie ein wild und sich weil
sie anderen gibt und die anderen wählen
uns nicht weil sie heim geben also wenn
man da eine klare richtung hätte wäre
das besser dann hatten wir absolut recht
was den afghanistan krieg betrifft da
hätten wir sogar gewinnen können und
unser chaotisches abstimmungsverhalten
bei den regierungsantrag zum abzug der
bundeswehr hat ist glaube ich sehr
geschadet also dass werden so die drei
sachen die mir als erster sein war nun
waren ja die letzten bundestag den
letzten landtagswahlen in den östlichen
bundesländern sachsen anhalt brandenburg
sachsen ich waren ja auch schon mit
schlechten ergebnissen
warum hat man dann anschließend nicht
sich hingesetzt und überlegt warum
können wir nicht die wähler wählerinnen
im osten wieder mehr einbinden als linke
also ich hoffe dass man das überlegt
habe wo sie müssen ja folgendes wissen
wir haben inzwischen sehr viel mehr
mitglieder aus den alten bundesländern
als aus den neuen das hat sich geändert
und ehemalige sed-mitglieder wie ich
sind die absolute rarität geworden die
ja meinem er dachte dadurch hat sich
natürlich einiges verändert aber ich
glaube dass die herzen auch verstehen
werden wie wichtig das thema ist und ich
bin ja ganz zufrieden mit den beiden
landtagswahlen heute wir haben zwar auch
leicht verloren aber das hält sich noch
in grenzen im unterschied zum bund und
auch im unterschied zum brandenburg
sachsen anhalt also sage ich mal müssen
wir uns beschäftigen was ist in
mecklenburg vorpommern anders gelaufen
was ist auch in berlin anders gelaufen
da waren sie natürlich energie und nicht
wie früher wo wir dann viel verloren
haben sondern diesmal haben sie
zumindest kaum verloren das heißt die
regierungsarbeit wurde schon
einigermaßen gewürdigt aber wie gesagt
nicht zu schnell und nicht in den alten
fehler verfallen wo nachher immer
erklärt dass herr b schuld ist unter wie
immer erklärt dass er schuld ist was ich
meine
die selbstkritische umgehen damit das
ist schon mal eine gute gute ansatz
finde ich sie haben eben die afghanistan
debatte schon angesprochen es gab danach
wieder fliehen und hier der eine sagte
dass dann wurde auf twitter antwortete
herr neuer herr lederer möchte die
partei verlegen weil er dafür gestimmt
hat und so was also diese
vielstimmigkeit innerhalb der linken das
ist doch das eigentliche problem oder
jetzt gesagt das hat uns früher mal
genutzt und schade sonst jetzt und
deshalb müssen wir uns jetzt mal klar
darüber werden wohin wir wollten damit
wir ein klares bild für die leute haben
und dann werden wir bestimmte wähler
wahrscheinlich verlieren aber andere
werden wir gewinnen und die können wir
dann auch an uns binden also ich werde
wenn ich denn direkt gewählt sein sollte
in treptow köpenick und dadurch einzigen
dem bundestag werde ich unsere fraktion
versammlung auch dafür ernsthaft
bestreiten sie können ja königsmacher
quasi sein falls es jetzt wirklich unter
die fünf-prozent-hürde geht naja ich
hoffe nicht ich bin ja ein spac optimist
und deshalb gehe ich mal davon aus dass
wir noch leicht nach oben gehen wir
werden aber was glauben sie denn
abschließend noch eine frage warum
braucht deutschland die linke was sind
themen wo sie sagen das ist doch
eigentlich das was deutsche wählerinnen
und wähler gebrauchen könnten aber wir
haben es jetzt nicht erreicht also
erstmal braucht man uns zur vereinigung
weil der osten sonst viel zu wenig
beachtung findet aber zweitens braucht
man bei allen fragen die es jetzt gibt
dringend für die soziale frage auch die
ökologische nachhaltigkeit muss in
sozialer verantwortung geschehen und das
muss unser schwerpunkt sein und drittens
glaube ich ist die friedensfrage sehr
wichtig und da sind wir auch sehr
berechenbar im unterschied zu den
anderen nicht vergessen dieser dieser
chaotischen völlig falsche krieg in
afghanistan ist von spd grünen union und
fdp immer gut geheißen und beschlossen
wurden nur wir haben von anfang an
gesagt er ist falsch und wir hatten
recht aber dann machen wir eben wieder
den fehler bei der abstimmung so werde
den regierungsantrag was mich auch
ärgert die aber war nicht zu ändern dann
warten wir mal ab wie sich die zahlen
weiter entwickeln alles gute und damit
gehe ich zurück ins studio und die
zahlen die sind nicht so gut aus für die
linken thorsten faas kurze frage bevor
wir gleich auf die fdp schauen der wahl
verlierer des heutigen abends das kann
man sagen dass neben der union auch
durchaus die linke ja absolut dass es
bemerkenswert wie tief die linke rutscht
weil sie eigentlich über viele jahre
kann man sagen so im bereich von 8 bis
10% sehr stabil stand ich glaube diese
zuspitzung auch das polarisieren gegen
rot grün rot das hat ihr letztlich nicht
genutzt sondern im gegenteil eher
geschadet weil auch unklar war was das
eigentlich für eine linke mehrheit
potenziell bedeutet und wir haben es in
den wählerwanderungen gesehen dann sind
doch viele lieber zur spd gegangen zu
olaf scholz weil sie den eigentlich als
kanzler gerne hätten und dass china ein
plausibler als eine wahl der linken und
gleichzeitig tut sich so ein konto auf
hätte ich es fast gesagt zwischen einem
bürgerlichen lager auf der einen seite
und einem vielleicht auch ihr linken
lager angeführt von olaf scholz aber
ganz interessant wird es sein wo die fdp
dort steht denn sie hat jetzt sehr
komfortable ausgangssituation sowohl mit
olaf scholz zu reden wir haben es gerade
bei katharina kühn im interview mit
herrn buschmann gehört als auch mit der
union und mit den grünen jeweils um
jamaika zu verhandeln ja absolut daran
merken wir dass die reine größe von
parteien in dieser situation wo es um
gespräche und verhandlungen gar nicht
die entscheidende rolle spielt sondern
grüne und fdp zwei königsmacher immer
ein bisschen schwierig eigentlich aber
trotzdem die sind in einer strategisch
starken position können sich im prinzip
auch stark machen in den gesprächen
interessanterweise umso aber je mehr sie
die seite wechseln müssen das ist das
spannende was wir hier sehen wenn die
fdp eine ampel koalition zur mehrheit
verhilft dann wird das teuer seien in
anführungszeichen denn dann muss die fdp
eben auf die andere seite auf die linke
seite hätten wir klassisch gewechselt
umgekehrt ist es für die grünen schwerer
einer schwarz gelben regierung zur
mehrheit zu verhelfen
das ist das was es so spannend macht
viele menschen haben noch so ein
lagerdenken im kopf aber es funktioniert
eben nicht mehr aber die sprünge auf die
andere seite die tun mitgliedern wie die
tum wählerinnen und wählern w und
deswegen macht man sich dann im
mindesten sehr teuer in verhandlung und
das zeigt sich ja letztendlich auch bei
dem knappen ergebnis zwischen cdu und
spd letztendlich um die frage mit wie
welchen ausgangs vorzeichen wenn man
eigentlich verhandeln kann aber für die
fdp und die grünen die ja schon 2017 ja
auch in verhandlungen waren damals unter
anderen vorzeichen klar aber was ist
jetzt wirklich für die beiden anders bei
dieser bundestagswahl
nabaida aber insbesondere auch die fdp
auch christian lindner haben sie sich
doch dieses mal sehr sehr klar dazu
bekannt oder erklärt dass sie regieren
möchten insofern steht diese option dass
man verhandlungen platzen lässt sie
steht eigentlich für insbesondere die
fdp auch für die grünen nicht im raum
insofern dass schlummer der noch die
groko mehrheit im hintergrund die werden
vielleicht union und spd so als drohung
an die beiden kleinen nutzen aber
eigentlich braucht es die nicht es
spitzt sich jetzt wirklich zu auf die
frage jamaika oder ampel ja und da wird
spannend sein was auch die csu dazu mit
zu sagen hat auf die blicken wer nämlich
jetzt gleich wollen aber vorher mal nach
münchen gucken denn dort hat den ganzen
abend mein kollege hans werner fittkau
verfolgt und die frage auch dort ist wie
das schlechte ergebnis für die csu bei
der derzeitigen hochrechnung lage liegt
sie bei
32,5 prozent dann durchaus zu bewerten
ist und was diese zahl bedeutet für die
anstehenden möglichen
koalitionsverhandlungen wenn sie denn
von armin laschet zukünftig geführt
werden
der wahlabend in münchen bringt die
erkenntnis dass auch die csu ein
wahlverlierer ist weil natürlich die
union im gesamten nach der ära merkel
nun um die macht in berlin wird kämpfen
müssen die csu geht aber die linie die
arme laschet heute abend in berlin
ausgegeben hat er hat ja beansprucht da
ist die union unter der führung der
union eine regierung gebildet wird
obwohl es im vorfeld hier aus münchen
die eine oder andere stimme gab die
besagt hat nein wenn wir auf platz 32
landen dann sollte doch eventuell die
spd die regierung
übernehmen und versuchen eine regierung
zu bilden das hat sich jetzt geändert an
diesem abend sowohl armin laschet als
auch markus söder haben da eine klare
position gesetzt man muss sehen wie das
ganze in der nacht im laufe der nacht
noch ausgeht wenn vor allem die
briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt sind
jedenfalls diese linie scheint erstmal
zu stehen jedenfalls bis morgen früh bis
die gremien her in der csu-zentrale
tagen und dann mitteilen wie es
weitergehen wird also das ist sozusagen
der kritische teil der andere teil wird
sich bezieht sich darauf dass die csu
vorher befürchtet hat nicht über die
fünf prozent hürde zu kommen in bayern
das ist nicht der fall sie legen so am
abend so jetzt bei 33 prozent haben also
die hürde aus eigener kraft geschafft
und die freien wähler das ist auch für
die csu auch wichtig waren es ebenfalls
nicht in den bundestag geschafft ich
hatte am frühen abend die gelegenheit
mit marc busch markus blume dem
generalsekretär der csu zu sprechen
vielleicht fangen wir damit an mit dem
was klar ist die csu hat hier in bayern
zwar verloren 5 bis 6 prozent aber den
sprung über die fünf-prozent-hürde
sehr wahrscheinlich geschafft was
überwiegt denn an diesem abend
der ärger über die verluste oder die
freunde des sie es geschafft haben das
ist natürlich ein ambivalenter abend
entscheidend war dass wir in eine
position kommen dass wir in deutschland
auch einen regierungsauftrag ableiten
können jedenfalls eine regierungsoption
haben für eine bürgerliche regierung wir
sind angetreten eine bürgerliche
regierung in diesem land zu bilden und
wir wollten ein linksbündnis verhindern
das ist uns gelungen es gibt die
möglichkeit seine bürgerliche regierung
zu bilden und da werden jetzt unser
augenmerk darauf richten jetzt haben sie
ja heute abend gesagt das ist doch so in
eine quasi pattsituation geschafft haben
wer auch der csu
hätte die csu mit angeschoben durch ihre
kampagne in der letzten jahr 14 tagen
warum haben sie denn nicht vorher schon
richtig dampf gemacht für armin laschet
und gegen allerdings verkaufen es ist ja
erst in den letzten wochen auch mit den
umfragen deutlich geworden dass hier
konkret ein linksbündnis in deutschland
droht und gleichzeitig ist erst in den
letzten wochen offenbar geworden dass
die spd und die grünen ein linksbündnis
eben auch nicht ausgeschlossen haben und
es war für uns der punkt wo wir gesagt
haben da müssen wir dagegenhalten und
insofern war das ein ergebnis eine
zuspitzung im wahlkampf die uns geholfen
hat auch dann noch mal extra viele
wählerinnen und wähler gerade auch in
bayern zu mobilisieren jetzt hat armin
laschet in berlin gesagt und markus
söder ebenfalls also ihr parteichef ja
wir wollen jetzt eine regierung unter
der führung der union bildern was ist
denn aber wenn die spd morgen für vorne
legt deswegen haben wir gesagt wir
müssen uns mal das ergebnis der langen
nacht abwarten dass in vielen
wahlkreisen sehr enges rennen wieder an
die endgültige zusammensetzung des
bundestags aussieht und alle weiteren
fragen bedient werden sich dann morgen
die parteigremien beschäftigen zunächst
mal war entscheidend linksbündnis zu
verhindern und auf der anderen seite
sicherzustellen dass wir in eine
position kommen dass eine bürgerliche
regierung möglich ist unter führung der
union dass ist rechnerische moment der
fall aber würde man sich dann in so
einer verhandlungssituation nicht sehr
stark erpressbar machen also große
verluste aber trotzdem versuchen mit der
fdp und den grünen ich sage es mal
salopp ins geschäft zu kommen die
aufgabe heißt dann ans land zu denken
das ist die zentrale aufgabe
und alles zu tun das was die menschen
noch erwarten dass ganz offensichtlich
eine regierung auch gebildet wird die
für stabilität steht die auch für
modernität steht diese ins werk zu
setzen das ist das was wir beitragen
möchten und wir tun das natürlich mit
einem ergebnis wo wir wissen da braucht
man eine ordentliche portion auch in der
zukunft muss man vielleicht noch mehr
drauflegen aber jetzt wird im moment
etwas was uns viele nicht zugetraut
hätten wenn sie mögen dürfen sie noch
einen satz zu den grünen sagen die
kanzlerkandidatin partei ist angetreten
er ins kanzleramt einziehen zu wollen
landet bei 14,6 prozent ist heißt immer
noch dass sie zugelegt haben aber das
kanzleramt ist weit weg ist das thema
jetzt endgültig durch man muss die
grünen als partei immer ernst nehmen wir
haben das getan wir werden das auch in
zukunft tun
aber am ende war richtig dass wir auch
unseren wahlkampf sehr stark
konzentriert haben auf die
auseinandersetzung mit olaf scholz mit
der spd zum schluss die hf de zeigt
deutlich nach unten glauben sie dass die
rechtspopulisten jetzt inszeniert
überschritten haben das bekämpfen der
afg bleibt eine daueraufgabe
man muss klare stoppschilder aufstellen
um viele bürgerinnen bürger in
deutschland haben gemerkt dass diese
partei paktiert mit querdenkern an
manchen stellen sogar mit extremisten
und glaube es ist einfach nicht
angebracht dass eine solche partei dann
quasi als verlängerter arm von solchen
bewegungen im parlament sitzt viele
bürger haben das realisieren und das
zeigt eben auch dass die afg hamburg zu
gast markus blume vielen dank für das
ist mal ich danke dir
es war ein spannender abend auch hier in
münchen die csu nimmt für sich in
anspruch sie haben es ja grad von
generalsekretär lohne gehört mit ihrer
kampagne gegen den linksruck in
deutschland noch einmal entscheidend
mobilisiert zu haben mithin wird sie
ihren einfluss bei den
regierungsgesprächen in berlin so ist
denn nach sondierungen unter führung der
union dazu kommt sie werden dann ihren
einfluss natürlich weiterhin versuchen
versuchen geltend zu machen wie es dann
morgen früh am montag wenn die gremien
getragen aussieht das werden wir dann
morgen früh sehen wenn wir bei dem
ergebnis klarheit haben wenn wir wissen
wer vorne liegt die union oder die spd
und welchen anteil die csu hier in
bayern
daran hatte damit zurück nach berlin
zumal anna-maria
und neuer gesprächsstoff hierfür unser
gespräch thorsten faas wir haben gerade
hans werner fittkau meinen kollegen
gehört im interview mit dem
generalsekretär der csu da gab es ja so
was im vorfeld wie eine magische grenze
von fünf der fünf prozent hürde dafür
muss man in bayern für die csu muss man
sich ein bisschen erklären über 30
prozent liegen das ist erreicht worden
aber trotzdem auch für die csu ein
schlechtes ergebnis da beugen sich jetzt
gleich alle drüber und sagen
wahrscheinlich war armin laschet daran
schuld zumindest ist dass das was man
wahrscheinlich am ehesten aus münchen
wird auch wenn man heute erst einmal den
kandidaten von cdu/csu amena shakir
gestützt hat der absolut man muss sehen
zwischen den beiden unions parteien gibt
es natürlich auch einen kampf wer
verantwortet dieses ergebnis die csu hat
heute schon darauf verwiesen die
wahlbeteiligung bayern war hoch man hat
dann doch am ende besser mobilisiert und
auch zugunsten der csu mobilisiert man
sieht auch an den direktmandaten als zu
befürchten war aber trotzdem ist es ein
schlechtes ergebnis und man muss sehen
so unumstritten markus söder in der
partei ist so richtig gute
wahlergebnisse hat er der partei bisher
nicht beschert insofern hat er natürlich
ein großes interesse daran dieses
schlechte ergebnis heute gerne bei der
schwesterpartei abzuladen und das eine
oder andere was wir gehört haben im
vorfeld aber auch heute abend ist glaube
ich genau in diesem lichte zu sehen
markus blume der generalsekretär der csu
hat gerade auch noch mal gesagt ein
wahlziel ist aus seiner sicht für die
csu und die cdu erreicht worden einen
linksruck zu verhindern gleichzeitig
wird er ist die spannende frage sein
inwieweit auch die csu einfluss darauf
nehmen wird jetzt bei den
sondierungsgesprächen die jetzt laufen
denn anders als noch vor einer woche wo
ist ganz klar hieß von der
zweitplatzierung der union leitet sich
noch kein regierungsanspruch ab aber
heute der elefantenrunde mit markus
söder aber jetzt auch bei den statements
von csu-politikern der doch gehört dass
das eine option ist die man ganz klar
spielen wird das wäre heute ein offener
affront gegen armin laschet gewesen der
ja für sich reklamiert hat in dieser
gespräch jetzt zu gehen aber trotzdem
die anderen aussagen sind ja
dokumentiert platz zwei ist ein problem
für die union hat die csu gesagt und da
ist sie jetzt gelandet insofern hat sie
da durchaus auch noch mal ein eine
herausforderung zu erklären was den
stimmungsumschwung eigentlich produziert
hat vielleicht hat man es am ende von
der größe abhängig machen anderthalb
prozentpunkte nicht klar genug auf platz
zwei um damit wirklich ins zweite glied
zu treten aber trotzdem das sind
spannende gespräche auch für die union
in nehmen so ganz selbstverständlich
heute abend an jamaika ist gesetzt die
unionsfraktion im deutschen bundestag
wird kleiner sein etc also das sind
schon noch mal schwarz schmerzhafte tage
die der union dabei vorstellen wenn man
wirklich verstanden hat was dieses
ergebnis eigentlich dann operativ
runtergebrochen bedeutet wir haben einen
wahlkampf ja auch gesehen der gezeigt
hat dass zwischen markus söder und armin
laschet ist nicht immer ganz einfach
gewesen ist und es mal vorsichtig
auszudrücken aber ich sag mal die stiche
die waren ja schon klar auch die absatz
bewegungen der csu klar zu machen wenn
das ergebnis jetzt so schlecht ist wie
es ist dann ist da für armin laschet als
kandidat schuld wir erinnern uns noch an
den an den langen kampf um die frage wer
wird eigentlich kanzlerkandidat der
union
wie sehr hat das auch letztendlich mit
blick auf das wahlergebnis jetzt die
parteien cdu/csu geschwächt und was
hätte es vielleicht bedeutet wenn ein
markus söder spitzenkandidat
kanzlerkandidat der union geworden wäre
allein die tatsache dass diese frage im
raum steht zeigt natürlich wie schwierig
die situation für armin laschet war er
hatte immer zwei ställe konkurrenten
konkurrenten angela merkel markus söder
beide mit hervorragenden werten in
umfragen wo man auch hätte erwarten
können dass sich das auf das
wahlergebnis der union niedergeschlagen
hätte armin laschet hatte diese werte
nicht im gegenteil wirklich schwierige
werte trotzdem hat er sich durchgesetzt
aber das war eine bürde und das führte
auch dazu dass man jedes wort was man
von seiten der csu der cdu gewählt hat
immer versucht hat zu interpretieren was
könnte das jetzt bedeuten ist das eine
stichelei oder nicht markus söder hat ja
auch damit einmal gespielt er kann sagen
was er will das wird immer gegen ihn
verwendet auch jetzt kein mitleid glaube
ich mit markus söder an der stelle aber
es zeigt einfach mädchen kommunikativen
rahmen der wahlkampf hier stattgefunden
hat und dass man sich letztlich für den
wahlkampf damit wirklich keinen gefallen
getan hatte na ja das wird auf jeden
fall spannend sein wie jetzt auch die
notierung in den kommenden tagen laufen
und was vor allen dingen hinter den
kulissen nachher vielleicht auch bei der
analyse dieses wahlergebnisses bewertet
wird von den schwesterparteien blicken
wir auf eine weitere partei hier in
unserer wahlsendung und zwar auf die afg
nach den letzten hochrechnungen hat sie
etwa 2,2 prozent verloren und mein
kollege alexander kähler ist bei der afg
und hat den abend für uns begleitet
die reihen hinter mir haben sich
gelichtet bei der afg es ist kaum noch
jemand hier in kaulsdorf das
spitzenpersonal ist auch längst
verschwunden so viel gab es wird abend
gar nichts zu feiern für die partei bei
der abgeordnetenhauswahl in berlin klar
abgeschmiert in mecklenburg vorpommern
besser abgeschnitten als erwartet und
bei der bundestagswahl so lala
wahrscheinlich unter dem ergebnis von
2017 da hatte man sich natürlich einiges
mehr erhofft eine gestärkte rolle im
neuen bundestag zu spielen da die afg
für koalitionsverhandlungen bekanntlich
nur irgendwo gebraucht wird ist das
wahlergebnis er ein vehikel für den
möglicherweise jetzt wieder
aufflammenden machtkampf in der afc im
vorfeld des bundesparteitags in
wiesbaden mitte dezember da wird ja die
parteispitze neu gewählt die docucolor
scheint trotz des durchwachsenen
wahlergebnisses dadurch ausgesetzt zu
sein jürgen hat offenbar größere
schwierigkeiten sich in der partei zu
behaupten es gibt sehr viel ärger in der
partei und einen wirklichen machtkampf
der jetzt nur durch den bund durch die
bundestagswahl etwas abgemildert war
also die nächsten wochen werden für die
partei entscheidend sein der
ko-vorsitzende partei jörg leuten der ja
bei der bundestagswahl gar nicht
angetreten ist der wahl zum interview
und bei phoenix
erneuten prognosen sagen 10 11 prozent
für die partei etwas weniger als 2017
wären sie spitzenkandidat gewesen hätten
sie mehr erreicht ich glaube die frage
ist völlig müßig ich bin nicht
spitzenkandidat gewesen ich habe jetzt
auch nicht angestrebt
so wollen wir darüber nicht so
diskutieren woran lag es denn dass das
bundestagswahlergebnis 2017
offensichtlich nicht erreicht oder dass
die partei sogar stärker abschneidet das
müssen wir analysieren ich bin kein
freund davon am am wahlabend dass
rauszuhauen womöglich mit
schuldzuweisungen zu operieren wir
müssen uns das in ruhe anschauen und
müssen eine nachwahlbefragung machen auf
saubere datenbasis dann schauen wir
warum es uns nicht gelungen ist das kann
man glaube ich sagen den die
historischen verluste der der cdu als
ehemals konservative kraft auf unsere
mühlen als neue konservativ
freiheitliche kraft umzulenken das haben
offensichtlich andere davon profitiert
als wir das bedauerlich da müssen wir
schauen woran das gelegen hat
schuldzuweisungen sind gutes stichwort
verantwortlich für ein wahlergebnis sind
vor allem die spitzenkandidaten sylvia 2
bei ihnen deswegen war meine frage am
anfang gar nicht so abwegig gemeint geht
das jetzt vor allen dingen wenn es eben
nicht das ergebnis gebracht hat dass
sich die afg erhofft hat geht das mit
den beiden spitzenkandidaten nach haus
müssen sich das jetzt
erklärungsbedürftig auch ihr wahlkampf
wir müssen den ganzen balkan analysieren
müssen das wahlprogramm analysieren wie
gewalt der spitzenkandidaten aber ich
wäre also ein lausiger parteichef wenn
ich jetzt anfänger mit schuldzuweisungen
an die adresse der spitzenkandidaten das
würde ich für völlig falsch halten wir
müssen uns das in ruhe anschauen woran
hat das gelegen das werden wir auch tun
man muss lernen und wir dürfen nicht
erwarten dass er in einer wahl nach der
anderen ist eine lineare
aufwärtsbewegung gibt die gibt es nicht
es gibt dabei auch mal
konsolidierungsphasen einer solchen sind
ja wohl und da müssen wir schauen wie
wie können wir weiter wachsen das
verlangt eine saubere analyse der daten
zur wahl danach sehen wir weiter es gibt
möglicherweise ja zwei ursachen das eine
ist dass die themen der afd nicht so
gepasst haben müssen sie sich nicht
überlegen wieder themen kann und in
zukunft für die afg anders aufgestellt
wird muss ich nicht breiter aufstellen
wir sind breit aufgestellt und lassen
sie mich sagen ich bin immer über kein
freund davon zu sagen welche themen
haben sie gesetzt die ereignisse setzen
den themen die ereignis hat das thema
aber nicht mithalten können doch haben
wir haben mehr zu afghanistan eine klare
position der anzug den klare position
wir haben zu der flutkatastrophe und
deren ursachen dem katastrophalen
versagen des katastrophenschutzes wir
haben sehr klare position also dieses
dieses fremming das gerne gemacht wer
seine ein themen partei ist erkennen bei
unsinnig wir haben alle themen die die
menschen derzeit umtreiben bespielt und
das ist richtig so nun müssen wir
schauen ob wir die menschen damit
erreicht haben wo waren wir damit
erfolgreich wo waren denn weniger
erfolgreichen was müssen wir anders
machen wird der machtkampf in der afg
wieder aufbrechen im vorfeld des
parteitags in wiesbaden da erwarten ja
viele einen showdown mit dem flügel den
sie repräsentieren und dem sehen zum
beispiel böcke repräsentiert das ist
eine geschichte die am wahlabend
wirklich kein thema sein darf wir machen
heute wahl analyse des wahlergebnisses
und mit dem bundesparteitag werden wir
uns in den kommenden wochen beschäftigen
aber das kann nicht jemand das heutige
ab da die wahlanalyse von der jungen
leuten da gerade gesprochen hat die geht
natürlich direkt oder leitet genau über
zu dieser macht frage die ich vorhin
schon angesprochen habe in der afd die
muss jetzt geklärt werden in welche
richtung sie gehen mit welchem personal
will zu gehen wie stellt sich die
bundestagsfraktion auf wie die partei
wie wird sie bei den nächsten wahlen
bestehen das sind alles offene fragen